I had Big Dreams as a 21 22 year-old kid
I think you're only lucky enough once or
twice in your life to be that naive and
I I say lucky because I think it's like
an unbelievable moment in time where I
sat down with a pen and pad and I was
like I'm going to make a TV network so
in today's episode of Deep dive I'm
joined By the Fantastic Colin and Samir
they are the podcasting Duo and YouTube
experts who for over the last 10 years
have been helping people navigate the
Creator economy they got their start
building a small online Network for
college La Cross and then they pivoted
into helping creators make the most of
the online space it was those early
videos that I made which were about
lacrosse that Samir saw and so when
Samir invited me to come to Los Angeles
for what was going to be just even 3
months I was like Wow someone will pay
me anything $700 a month to go do this
because I didn't study this so it was a
no-brainer was like yeah absolutely
their main channel has over 1 million
subscribers they've interviewed the
likes of Mr Beast and MKBHD and Mr who's
the boss and me we never talk about the
start of the Colin inir podcast which is
essentially what has become come our
entire career which was in 2018 when we
were really down and out having an
existential crisis cuz we couldn't make
any money as creatives and decided as
almost an act of therapy to get on mics
to have open conversations with each
other you guys are the Creator economy
guys like you are the seeming you've
somehow become the experts in the
Creator economy where you've interviewed
people like Mr Beast and Tim Ferris and
like all of the big names uh and also uh
me on your on your show a couple weeks
ago all the big names and ali abdal um
how in in a nutshell how did you guys
get to becoming these like thought
leaders within the Creator economy what
was the doing that in a nutshell is
going to be very difficult I mean what
how how I would describe it is just that
it it took us a really long time to
figure it out ourselves and so we found
people to talk to to ask how do you do
it so so it wasn't that we're the
experts we just talked to a lot of
people who had done it um and granted we
have been in the space for 12 years I
think maybe something that a lot of
people don't know about us is that we
uploaded our first YouTube video
together in
2011 and that is a long time ago so we
actually have been uploading to YouTube
for a very long time and have met a lot
of people along the way and have had a
lot of a lot more failures than had
successes and I think that creates an
interesting you know dynamic when you
have the opportunity to have more
failures than than success and in this
version of us because there kind of have
been two in this version of Colin and
Samir we spent the majority of the time
actually helping other YouTube creators
helping them with their Productions and
then once we had a podcast and a place
to speak with them they were willing to
come on the show to talk about it so I
think that's part of it is that we were
behind the scenes while trying to be be
in front of the camera as well so I
guess you guys have been doing this this
this YouTube thing for 12 years now
since way before the word Creator
economy was even a thing since way
before it was I guess around about 2012
was when people really started to make
money in the space is my my vague
understanding of what's going on um it
it feels like a lot of young people
these days want to become creators um to
what extent would you recommend being a
Creator as a career and what are the
yeah what are the pros and cons I guess
see when I hear that a lot of young
people want to be creators I try and
think about what is it that they're
seeing that makes them want that and I
feel like sure money is part of it but I
think another part of it is confidence
in identity you can quickly assume that
a lot of the creators you follow are
very confident in who they are if
they're willing to put it on camera and
I think those are two very attractive
things like money and confidence in
identity and I think there are many ways
to get both of those before you go about
pursuing this career and I think it's
important to try and think about how you
can
pursue confidence in identity perhaps
before you
Embark I would would wholeheartedly
agree with that and also say that it's
not even some about like us recommending
to you if this is something you should
do I think it's just um there's there's
people who can't help it and I would say
that that we are some of those people
who just can't help it we've been doing
this since 2011 and as I mentioned we've
had more failure than success that is a
completely irrational thing to do to
work on something day in and day out
that is not working through you know
your late 20s at times through not
making much money to get together and
get excited about uploading a video to
the internet is irrational and so I
think that there's some people who just
can't help it and if you are actually
that type of person you will become a
Creator because you will just keep going
and I think that um you do have to
really evaluate what it is you're
looking for is it the outcome that
you're seeing is the outcome of
validation um
recognition money uh is is that the
outcome you're looking for actually the
majority of being a Creator is the
process of creating so you have to
really understand your relationship with
your the process of creating yeah in a
way like are you embarking on this
journey for the sake of the journey or
for the sake of the destination yeah
because I mean everyone can you have to
see it for yourself everyone can tell
you the there's like no real Merit to
the destination right like the
destination doesn't exist you reach
there and then you're like now I just do
more of this I remember when I felt like
we had achieved some level of success
and I was like oh so success just means
doing more of what we used to do but in
a more comfortable way it's the same
thing you know when we were first
starting out we were figuring out ideas
and then filming them and then editing
them and then coming up with a thumbnail
and then putting it up it's the exact
same thing we do today it's just
sometimes more comfortable and sometimes
more stressful and different problems
arise from it there's a nice um quote I
think I think it's from Zen Buddhism or
something like that which is kind of
what happens before you reach enlight
Enlightenment and what happens after and
so the quote is before Enlightenment uh
chopwood carry water after Enlightenment
chopwood carry water I think of that in
the Creator economy it's fair Fairly
similar like the things that we were
doing when we hadn't made made it and we
were making videos and making no money
are basically identical to what we're
doing now and making decent money from
the thing which is kind of weird I me
even this morning we got a text from our
friends uh yes Theory and there're
people who we work behind the scenes
with and they texted us this morning a
picture of themselves at a computer
editing the same way that they were
doing like 5 years ago when we met them
and yet they've experienced what maybe
they have what seven eight million
subscribers now same thing it's this
like you look at the photo of them at
the computer today this morning and we
just go like this is amazing it's still
the guys at a computer yeah okay let's
talk about money um you've guys have
been doing this for 12 years uh at what
point like how how much money were you
making in the early days and if you're
open to sharing how much money are you
making now like how do they work yeah so
in the early days none um you know the
way it worked in the early days was we
started I I graduated college and then
started a company called the Lacrosse
Network which was a sports media
business about lacrosse my vision was
I'm going to make a television network
for the sport of Lacrosse a sport I grew
up playing very niche um can't make a TV
network can't pitch it to anyone on TV
so okay let's make it on the internet
that that was the you know base premise
I had Big Dreams you know as a as a 21
22y old kid I was like I I didn't I
think you're only lucky enough once or
twice in your life to be that naive and
I I say lucky because I think it's like
an unbelievable moment in time where I
sat down with a pen and pad and I was
like I'm going to make a TV network
that's a ludicrous thought right like to
have that thought at 34 years old with
everything I know now I'd be like I
wouldn't even allow that thought to go
the next step let alone a TV network for
a sport that not that many people play
the majority of people who play it
actually play it on the entire other
side of the country yeah and most people
probably also haven't heard of it like I
heard of Lacrosse when I got to
University I was like lacrosse that's
the thing okay cool fair enough at that
time did you think money was going to be
something that came like that's why you
were doing it was like this is a is a
money thing no it wasn't money driven it
was like I'm really passionate about
this community this community has given
me a lot like I found a lot of identity
in that Community I found a lot of
friends I that was what I did in college
I coached a team I was like very
involved in the community so I wanted to
give back to the community but I'm not
going to say it was fully pure I was
like I want to be in the entertainment
business I know you can make a lot of
money in the entertainment business I
grew up in La um and that was a huge
part of it that's not you know at 21
years old that's a huge part of it and I
think we talk about a lot that the era
that we were in at that time was the
startup era
the sexiest thing you could be a part of
or have was a startup and you know when
you think about the social network that
movie you know Facebook Snapchat Evan
Spiegel these are 21 22 year old startup
Founders who were becoming Mega
millionaires so everyone had you know an
idea for a startup at that time long
story short um as it sounds like that
was not a quick way to make money to
start a lacrosse based YouTube channel
with another friend and then fly Callin
from you know uh Colorado to come live
in LA I mean this was not a way a quick
way to make money um nor did it ever
really make money in the three years
that we built it so how are you how are
you sustaining yourselves in that time
yeah so the The Way We Were sustaining
ourselves was was two ways one from my
savings and two from uh my dad runs a
clothing company and basically I said
we're a group of creatives give us
essentially a contract to do your
creative work work and we will do the
Creative work basically 9 to5 like
printing logos on no like uh photography
for the clothing lines photo shoots
campaigns website design graphic design
Colin design the logo for my dad's
clothing company that's actually just
changed after 12 years yeah it was a 12
year logo it ran it had a good run yeah
um it's funny cuz looking back even for
me when I moved out to work with Samir I
did not assume that this would be a
company that would make money because I
was a member of the lacrosse Community I
kind of understood how big it was didn't
fully understand YouTube but just was
like okay I want to come out for 3
months and learn and I even said in my
first email but I also want to be
involved in some of the other projects
things you have going on because I just
wasn't sure that money was going to be a
reality so this is kind of so a lot like
a lot of people I know who are in like
their early 20s for example would think
that okay your 20s are for grinding your
20s are to get the job at Mackenzie and
to do the Consulting thing and to set
yourself up to maybe then follow your
passion further down the line but it
seems like you guys went for the I'm
passionate about X let me do the thing
well I I'll back up I know the question
was about money so I want to be you know
respond to that question to give you a
frame of reference the deal with Colin
was come out for a three-month
internship will'll pay you $700 a month
oh okay that was the deal I don't know
if you remember that that was the deal
to give you a frame of reference of
where we were at uh and that was a big
deal for us to to spend that kind of
money um so just to back up about like
how did this come about I grew up in LA
was always into film I was into you know
performing I was into uh music was
primarily what I was into when I was a
kid I thought I was going to end up
being in a band a touring band that's
what I thought yeah we'll put some Boll
if you playing the guitar I thought I
thought that's what the outcome of my
life would be like of course I'm GNA I'm
going to be in a band we would perform
like a ton in high school and um I had a
lot of dreams of of becoming a performer
some type of Entertainer um I went to
film school i' I you know ended up being
pretty good in my film school to the
point where they placed one person in a
job in Hollywood and it was me uh as an
editor and so I got placed on a film
called Ides of March um and I was an
assistant editor on that film bottom
ofth the barrel assistant editor a job
that today is done by AI but I was there
to you know the the this thing I
basically synced audio and video that
was it um for the dailies so dailies
came in every day I would sync them and
then pass them to the next editor um I
sat in a pitch black room every day uh
the the distance from the entrance of
the studio to the editing room was
probably like 100t but I would walk as
slowly as possible just in case a
producer saw me and they were like there
he is that's the guy put him in the
movie uh never happened but I would sit
in this room and I just like didn't get
it I was like this is not the
entertainment industry like all the
editors were in cargo shorts and hoodies
and were kind of overweight and just
sitting in this dark room I was like
this is not what I imagined at all um
and I I went out to lunch with the head
editor and he asked me he was like you
you know you seem a little kind of not
into this is this what you want to be
doing and I was like I think I want to
make stuff I don't know how to explain
it any further but I just know that I'm
capable I can edit something top to
bottom I can also film something I can
also come up with an idea and I can also
be in it and uh he said he gave me the
best advice I've ever received he said
so here's the deal you are an assistant
editor from me right now and you're
pretty good I like having you around I
will hire you again as an assistant
editor and I'll recommend you to my
friends as an assistant editor and one
day in 10 years maybe you could be me is
that what you want I was like absolutely
not and he said okay so I'm gonna urge
you to leave right now and go do exactly
what you want to do exactly what's in
your head go do that because in 10 years
from now you'll get the opportunity to
do more of that whatever that
is and I left and that's right when I
said you know what I want to do
everything so I'm gonna make my own
network because then I can do everything
I'm gon I can film I can be in it I can
edit I can make the programming
decisions I'm gonna do everything yeah
so that's that's how it came about
because then it was like so what can I
talk about the thing that I know the
most about the thing that I know the
most people in the community that I'm
organically a part of of
Lacrosse and where can I take this
network the only place where they can't
say no the
internet so that's how that came
about there's so many ideas that are
just SP sparking in my mind um one of
the questions I've been thinking about a
lot
is what would you do if you won the
lottery what would you do if money was
no object and I I often like to I I ask
myself that question quite a lot in
terms of helping figure out like what
are my core values what are the things I
intrinsically want to do but I also find
that if I'm doing a sort of having
coffee with a friend and they're like
asking for advice or any on anything
I'll just open up with that question be
like hey you know what do you actually
want to do and that's a scary question
to answer for a lot of people because
for a lot of people they're like I don't
know like we're so used to thinking in
terms of being a cog in a machine the
schooling system and everything like
that that it's if we imagine the
constraints lifted from us it's almost
hard to imagine what we would like to do
and often when people do imagine that
they they they would say some things
like well to do music I'd love to write
books I'd love to do art I'd love to
create stuff but then the immediate push
back in their own minds is oh but you
can't make money from that and so is
it's like a lot of people seem to have
these creative aspirations but I held
back with the but it's not it's never
going to make money
yeah I was lucky enough to be a terrible
student and so I knew I would be a
terrible employee so I I it was never in
my mind that I could go be an employee
somewhere so that that was never an
option for me and my dad's an
entrepreneur um it just wasn't I was it
just wasn't an option yeah different for
Colin so how did how did you decide to
take the plunge well I
mean I guess if I'm backing up for me I
grew up in an area where everyone kind
of went into finance and wanted to be a
banker I kind of thought that's what I
would do I went to college and was a
business major coming in in the business
school for no other reason than I just
thought that's what you're supposed to
do you go to college you go do business
and you get out you do business you make
money and
got into school and found myself like
very uninspired quickly by my accounting
and statistics and finance classes and
bought a camera after I graduated and
knew that I wanted to do something
entrepreneurial like Samir was saying it
was like the startup era when it was all
about having your own company your own
thing and I was like all right I don't
know what it is but if I know how to
film I know how to edit I know how to
put up the website and how to design the
logo then I'll be Leaps and Bounds ahead
if I just know how to do all the those
things that I think an entrepreneur
needs to do yeah uh then I'll be all
right I'll at least be a little bit
ahead um so for me I just found it
interesting from an identity standpoint
and I went into college thinking I was
some sort of way I was a business-minded
person and came out realizing actually
no I'm much more of a creative person I
want to work on Creative projects and
that's kind of what got me going um so
yeah I mean when I graduated from
college I was working at the front desk
of a hotel and after I would get off
work I would go film and edit just to
teach myself and it was those early
videos that I made which were about
lacrosse that Samir saw yeah and so when
Samir invited me to come to Los Angeles
for what was going to be just even three
months I was like Wow someone will pay
me anything $700 a month to go do this
because I didn't study this so it was a
no-brainer was like yeah absolutely nice
so you guys sorry I was just going to
say to answer the question about money
the first the first three years you know
the exposure to the company uh I think
was around $770,000 a year total what
does exposure mean meaning like how much
we spent because we used one of my dad
my dad had a warehouse he wasn't using
in Downtown LA and we moved in there um
which was you know an interesting
experience there was like cockroaches
and a a bathroom that barely worked and
you know it was it was a true cool
startup experience but we were lucky
enough to have a space cuz prior to that
we were in my bedroom um which is
actually really fun and cool and funny
um and like stereotypical startup I was
living at home so I I didn't receive any
money um for basically up until we sold
the company um and you know it was an
interesting experience because it was
very it was very tense I would say like
within two years because two years in
it's like okay we have a creative
contract with my dad's company this
doesn't feel good we aren't making any
money
you know this isn't this this isn't
right like this doesn't feel right but
what did feel right was we were creating
these videos having a lot of fun
creating the videos and there was an
audience reacting to it and I was just
like how do we hold on to this so then
we started doing we were like what you
know we can be a creative shop for other
people and so we did random things we
did uh we would make websites for $1
thousand and I remember having an
argument with Colin and and um Julian
who was uh the guy who I started the
company with um about the ,000 I was
like that's that's not enough we should
charge more and I remember uh Julian
said to me like well we need to at least
do one thing so that we can you know
have a proof of concept and sell more
and so like we would get into arguments
about how much we could charge we we
started building computers for people we
just did whatever we could figure out
because we were like we have to keep
this YouTube channel going but we have
to make just enough money to get bought
yeah it's like amongst the three of us
whoever had a certain type of skill set
was like all right we'll charge for that
skill set you know whatever it is Colin
had a friend who needed stickers I
remember he came into the the office one
day and he was like uh my friend needs
stickers you think we could make
stickers and I was like yeah we can make
stickers we charged him 800 bucks to
make stickers and we bought them for
like 500 so it's like made $300 you know
it's just random things to just keep the
YouTube channel going um I think we had
a belief that I had a belief that
advertising would come a lot
quicker but again I was I was riddled
with naite at the time that you know yes
people were making money on YouTube no
people were not making money with
lacrosse
videos so
um luckily enough we got acquired by a
sports Media company and and when I say
acquired it was an aqua hire so one of
the greatest yes there was you know
money exchanged but one of the greatest
things was that they gave us all jobs um
and so we all had jobs at a company and
got to continue working on the Lacrosse
Network but also immediate within weeks
we're working with dude perfect and so
immediately we were like okay now we're
working with successful creators and
athletes we started working with Jeremy
Lynn started working with um Giannis uh
started working with all these NBA
players and teaching them about
everything we knew about YouTube which
again in 2014 for guys who had been
doing YouTube for three years we were
the most experienced guys in sports
YouTube I remember having so much
imposter syndrome when we first got
acquired thinking why are they doing
this I'm going to get fired they made a
huge mistake col thought he was going to
get fired within the first two days I I
remember a call with with Colin because
we were working on something and
basically immediately the aqua hire
meant like our stuff went over there it
got bought by the company and absorbed
so we did keep working on that but again
it wasn't making really much money maybe
by that time we had covered like I think
that year we had made $90,000 so like at
least we were covering our own oh like
90k divided by three so you on like 30k
celeries yes yes it's not too bad and
that's with like year three of the
business yes yes okay and how much money
you're making now though however
comfortably you sharing that I think I I
actually this is not a cop out I don't
know the actual 100% like number but you
know we are we are making you know in
the in the millions um I would say
probably this year we'll cover two
million if not a little bit more than
that revenue or profit uh Revenue nice
yeah and what sort of margins are you
guys running out uh we we have taken on
a lot more expense this year um we've
taken on a lot more expense we have a
bigger office we have a bigger team
we're kind of in in a of like investing
into the company so this year I think
our our profit is less I mean one of the
great things right now is that I am
pretty far removed from this now we have
hired people to help us with our
finances and it's kind of crazy for me
because even as I say that number I'm
like I don't even I I know that that's
some that somewhat accurate but it might
be off and we're halfway into the year
and I'm not 100% sure and that is scary
but also really freeing because one of
my goals this year was to lean into
being Talent yeah you know like I want
to be good at the craft of
being present during more creative
projects I don't want to sit in a
creative project and think about how
much money it
represents I think also that's after
years of you know the the era that we're
talking about with Lacrosse Network
being 10 plus years ago over 10 years
ago it was no money no money got a real
got a job got acquired but it was
essentially just a job for very normal
salary then we left those jobs and then
it was no money no money no money
negative money no
money you know a little bit and then
2022 was it right the first year that we
really hit being last year of course we
had deals that came in that allowed us
to exist yeah but for the first year we
actually made money at the end of the
year it was like oh there's money in the
bank yeah yeah there was a surplus of
money at the end of last year time ever
was last year which was essentially yeah
us getting paid right like we we do
distributions at the end of the year and
that's when we know how much money we
make right um so it's it's a really
interesting trajectory because colins's
right there was years where um you know
when so basically we we sold the company
we sold Lacross Network we um got into
the world of uh this company had great
jobs had a really great I I call it our
MBA we learned everything about the
Creator space you know what what is
referred to as the Creator economy was
getting figured out in real time in that
company right we were learning about how
how companies were working and and and
everything so um that was a really great
experience and we got I would say
overconfident in that company we felt
really good we were able to grow the
Lacrosse Network to become a profitable
division of that company which was like
really impressive to me um and very
exciting and then we were able to help
you know people like dude perfect or you
know any of the other clients there
figure out their revenue monetization I
felt really good and so we decided Ed
one day over pasta that we would leave
uh and start our own thing and primarily
because we didn't want to do Sports
forever we didn't want to be the
lacrosse guys forever we we were in love
with the process of making videos but
not in love with sports um and so we
were like oh Casey neistat's vlogging
he's got a Channel with his name on it
we could do it right Colin and Samir and
uh I remember everyone at the company
kind of speculated that we had some
something going on we were we were we
had raised some money or we were joining
another company and we actually just
left M we just left our jobs and I think
the first week Colin was like on the
beach yeah lost and called me and he was
like
so what do we do and I was like at home
and I was like I I feel like you started
directing your energy into your family
business very quickly after it was like
all right well that's done and now you
know I'm needed over here I'll plug in
over there and I was just on the beach
like this is wrong something's wrong
here so we got together and just were
like okay yeah you're right let's just
start making videos and we just started
making videos like no plan one of the
most ill-advised things but again this
was the second time that we were lucky
enough to be this naive uh to just be
like we'll just start it we'll just make
videos we'll see what happens let's say
you were speaking to um a let's say
someone in their 20s they've just
graduated University May they've tried a
job for six months and they're like
screw the job like job's not for me I
want to become a
Creator what would you if you if you had
to give this person if you were their
like mentors and you you you were giving
them a road map what would be the road
map now that it's 2023 to succeed in the
Creator economy you have to buy the
course to find out you can't answer that
yeah I'll invoice you after no I'm
kidding um so as I look back on that I
think the one thing that we always agree
upon was that we went into um making the
Colin and smeir Channel with being very
like um selfish creators which is
completely fine it's like here's what we
want to make yeah right here's what we
want but if you're if you want to be a
Creator then you have to be empathetic
towards the audience and we were not an
artist has no empathy to the audience
right an artist paints something and
says this is what I wanted to paint I
don't care what you think about it and
as if you want to be an artist that is a
thing if you want to be a Creator you
have to be empathe towards the audience
there's a balance between what you want
to make what the audience wants and what
the platform wants there's three things
that make up you know what you want to
make what the audience wants and what
the platform wants yeah okay that's
something that we call content Market
fit is finding you know that that right
in the middle of that is content Market
fit what you want to make what the
audience wants to watch and what the
platform wants this episode is very
kindly brought to you by none other than
hu now I've been a pain customer of hu
since 2017 I first discovered it in my
5ifth year of medical school and if you
haven't heard of it it's basically a
meal in a bottle and in that meal you
get a balanced mixture of carbohydrates
and fats and proteins and fiber and it
also contains 26 different vitamins and
minerals and each meal has around 400
calories and 22 g of protein so it's
pretty reasonable in terms of protein
count and because I tend to be pretty
busy and there's always stuff going on I
tend not to really have time to get a
healthy breakfast or a healthy lunch and
so I'll often use heu ready to drink as
a replacement for my breakfast or my
lunch they've got eight different
flavors that are available my two
favorites are banana and salted caramel
so if you find those you should check
them out and even though hu as a company
started off online direct to Consumer
recently they've propagated amongst all
of like the grocery stores in the UK at
least and so I've been seeing it out and
about everywhere which is pretty cool
and very excitingly we also have an
episode with Julian Hearn who is the
founder of hu back on this podcast from
season 1 and so that episode was a real
masterclass entrepreneurship and it was
really cool seeing kind of hearing the
story of exactly how heel came together
so head over to heel.com deepdive and
thank you so much heel for sponsoring
this episode this episode is sponsored
by kajabi and they've actually got
something really valuable for all of our
deep dive listeners now if you haven't
heard of kajabi it's basically a
platform that helps creators diversify
their revenue with courses and
membership sites and communities and
podcasts and coaching tools so it's one
of the best places for creators and
entrepreneurs to build a sustainable
business we started using kajabi earlier
this year and as soon as we started
using it we were like oh my God why
haven't we been using this product for
the last 3 years it's got everything
you'd possibly need for running an
online course or hosting an online
community or building an online coaching
business and it essentially makes it
really easy to run your entire online
business from payments to marketing
tools to analytics kajabi has everything
that we creators need all in one place
and actually you don't necessarily need
a huge audience to generate a
sustainable income a Creator on kajabi
can for example make $100,000 by
converting just 350 customers a year
depending on your price points and in
fact there are creators on the platform
that are making millions of dollars
every year with fewer than 100,000
followers across the social media
platforms we've been using kajabi to
host all of our online courses since the
start of 2023 from our $1 part-time
YouTuber foundations to help people
start off on their YouTube Journey all
the way up to our $5,000 package for the
part-time YouTuber accelerator which
gives you access to me and my team and
kajabi does not take any cut of what you
earn creators keep and own everything
the way kajabi makes money is through
the monthly subscription fee and even
though we generate like literally
millions of dollars every year from
kajabi we're still only paying them a
couple hundred a year and actually in
their lifetime kajabi have paid out
over6 billion dollar to creators that's
billion with a be and over a thousand
creators have become millionaires
through products on the platform now
back in May 2023 I did a keynote at a
kajabi in real life kajabi Heroes Event
in Austin Texas and in that keynote I
talked about the exact steps that I use
to grow my business from zero to over
$2.5 million per year from course
Revenue alone now people paid for the
pretty expensive tickets to watch this
keynote at the kajabi hero live event
but as an exclusive deal for deep dive
listeners kajabi have very kindly
offered to provide the recording of that
keynote completely for free to anyone
who listens to this podcast so if you're
interested in getting completely free
access to that keynote just head over to
kajabi.com Ali that's kajabi.com Ali and
that'll be linked in the show notes and
the video description as well you just
enter your email address and then you
will get the recording of that keynote
completely for free whether or not you
ever become a kajabi customer so thank
you so much to kajabi for sponsoring
this episode okay so let's say I'm like
you know I really want to be a music
YouTuber I love Kurt Schneider I love
that voice Avenue era of uh popular song
covers on YouTube and I want to I want
to make money on YouTube playing guitar
and singing songs and I'm and you guys
are my mentors how would How would how
how how would we be having that
conversation I would say if you want to
make money figure out another way to
make money to start I think that's one
of the biggest mistakes we made when we
started this YouTube channel was that we
did not really think about where money
would come from and we assumed that it
would come pretty immediately from this
new pursuit of creating YouTube videos
because we had just come from a
background in YouTube why wouldn't it we
kind of thought we understood how that
would work but it it made us make
choices that were based out of fear
taking different production projects and
things that took energy away from what
we were trying to put into this creative
Pursuit so I think if you love music and
you want to make money from it figure
out a different way to start to make
money from it so that you can just focus
on the creative side and when it comes
to the the video making side the first
question I would ask you is who's the
audience oh I'd be like I don't know
like people who want covers of Ed sharan
songs on YouTube okay and how much of
that is available to
them loads of people Shar so i' ask you
to scan that right and say okay cool now
go study who else is doing what you want
to do why are they watching what's
interesting about it you know like do
they have space to watch five of these
in a row is that the culture of this
audience where else do they hang out on
the internet outside of um YouTube and a
lot of what we've learned I would say
over the past 12 years is this process
of studying audiences because we are
again we are part of the equation but
the audience is we're playing p with an
audience right that's what the internet
is really great at we throw something
out the audience reacts to it and we
understand oh interesting that's what
you what you guys like that's what you
didn't like okay let me try this oh okay
now I just learned something new about
you guys so creating being a creator for
the internet is a collaborative process
with the audience and so you have to
deeply before you embark on this journey
Define who you're speaking to and
understand them it's okay for that to
evolve I don't want to say that you have
to put yourself in like a very tight box
in the beginning but that's the first
question I would ask you is lead with
who you are speaking to why is it
valuable to them y because you are
asking people to invest time in your
edar and cover so what's their return on
that investment how does it differ from
what someone else is offering it's like
somewhat similar to just general
entrepreneurship or launching a product
like is there enough space for you in
this market if you are going to enter
that market are you different are you
singular do you stand out or are you
replaceable and a lot of times you're
not going to you should think about it
up front and you should figure that out
but a lot of times that's going to come
from
starting but I do think sometimes people
would get Leaps and Bounds ahead if they
were more aware of the market they were
entering or the space before they did it
yeah yeah the way that I I I think of
this that I that I teach this in our
course is um you know sort of three
levels level one get going level two get
good and level three get smart so get
going I would say is like the first
three videos just like put the videos on
there it doesn't matter like don't
overthink it because loads of people get
stuck in overthinking um especially if
they've come from a background where
they've been to University and done well
or they've already been in a job and
done well suddenly to go into YouTube
it's like oh the overthinking stops them
from doing from doing anything just make
a handful of videos see how it feels see
what the vibe is and then I would say
level two is get good which is still
while you have a day job like get good
at the craft of actually making videos
and get to a point where the stuff
you're making no longer makes you cringe
and as soon as you stop cringing at your
stuff that means it's reached some level
of internal quality but if you start
getting responses from the audience like
like comment subscribes whatever the
thing might be that's an external
barometer for is the thing you're making
actually good and at that point now that
you know how to make a thing that is
good then we can worry about like are we
treating this like a hobby or are we
treating it like a business if it's a
hobby do what you want have fun do your
Ed un covers no one cares if we're
treating it like a business a business
exists to serve an audience and there
for like all the things around treating
it like a business I I would say that's
the other you know that's the question
before the question about the audience
is like why why do you want to do it
right is it is it a hobby or is it do
you have commercial intent or do you not
know yet you don't have to know when you
start you know like commercializing your
creativity is a very complicated thing
to do it's not clean you know it's not a
clean process what do you mean
creativity is a very at least for me
like coming from you know growing up and
and playing music I think about the
concept of writing songs and how
enjoyable it was to write a song and
think about how like songs would just
come I had a lyric book I would write I
would just kind of enjoy the process of
writing music um if that became a
commercial thing right now I don't know
what my relationship with that would be
if I had to do it right or if someone
pays you to do it and if people start
paying you to do it you all of a sudden
are evaluating your ideas based on a
value system that is quantitative and a
quantitative value system we all know on
YouTube is a uh it's a very just I think
it's a tricky thing to do with your
creativity you think about a creative
video idea you're like I love this idea
you put it out it tanks do you still
love the idea or did something just
happen did something just change about
what you feel about the
idea you know like you finish the video
you love it and you put it out and based
on if it's a one out of 10 or a 10 out
of 10 you your emotions towards it might
change dramatically yeah there are
videos that I've put out that I thought
this is really bad and it does well I'm
like oh you know what it was good all
along and you know what I actually love
that video now and I would do another
one yeah so that just immediately when
you have performance-based
creativity it's a completely different
thing than
creativity have you ever worked with a
creative person hired a creative person
who's not motivated by
money you may not attract that type of
person I don't think so honestly like
like even hearing you guys talk about
creative stuff that's completely the
opposite World from where I've grown up
which is all about like imagine like
imagine working with someone who doesn't
care about the paycheck they really care
about the final outcome of the work in
the way that they would prefer it to be
oh I have students like this on my
YouTuber it's so frustrating heard about
these people yeah when they say why is
my channel not growing and I'm
like like who who's the audience like
what's like why should watch you it's
like oh no but I I really wanted to make
this and I I think it's really I think
my message is really important yeah okay
but like clearly other people don't so
like think mistake the sometimes
creatives mistake what's happening on
YouTube for creativity
uh that there isn't a lot of creativity
on YouTube yeah not that there isn't but
again like let's take a look at the film
industry yeah why are there so many
Spider-Mans because it's commercially
successful it works because it puts
butts in
seats okay that's just like the simplest
thing I can say about the film business
right so if you want to be in the film
business if you were to decide I want to
be in the film business you're playing
by those rules what puts butts and seats
if you want to be a filmmaker you can be
a filmmaker but you might not play with
the film business it might intersect a
couple of times but those are it's okay
for those to be decoupled yeah right
it's like how it's like how someone who
enjoys making coffee is very different
to someone who runs a profitable coffee
business or coffee shop completely
different things completely different
things with like minor overlap but like
broadly completely different things yeah
different things um col said this to me
one time he was like I think uh we we
thought YouTube was about monetizing
self-expression but it's
not does that make sense it can be of
course within certain confines and in
many ways you look at our Channel what
we're doing right now your channel sure
you are monetizing a bit of
self-expression but there are
compromises which gets increasingly more
difficult when you're compromising on
yourself yeah yeah you know and and all
this to say we found a format that for
me at least I feel has allowed for me to
be myself and an uncompromised version
of myself and have that intersect with
commercial viability and I feel really
lucky about that because there was a lot
of versions of like attempts at YouTube
that I was not I was not being 100%
myself you know and I I if I was good at
not being myself I would have pursued
acting which I wanted to do but I wasn't
good at it I can't pretend for that long
um and so I feel very grateful that we
found a format where it's like when you
watch our videos like I that is me I am
Samir in that context I'm not playing a
role like we had coffee with James
Hoffman before this um at his coffee
shop and we spent three hours with him
basically funny enough felt like we did
a podcast without recording it it's like
it's exactly the conversations we enjoy
having it's exactly the people I'm
interested in it's exactly how I show up
in those conversations and I feel really
lucky that that is what we get to to do
but for the record I'm a paid actor just
to make sure that that's clear for
everyone listening and watching I do
have to ask myself how many of these
conversations would I do if there if it
wasn't tied to you know Commercial
Success how much would I upload how much
you right like you you do have to think
about that too it's like okay is this
what you know and that's what running a
creative business is you know and I
think that's that's the thing the advice
I would give is like just get really
smart on understanding what making it
means to you like what is making it to
you what is what does that mean to like
make it on YouTube what are you
imagining in your head and then also
like you know do you deeply
authentically care about providing value
to the audience that you've told me you
you want to have because if you do then
you can have a long career um then
you're going to wake up every day and be
like okay this lifestyle is really
enjoyable the process of making videos
is really enjoyable I get to do the
thing I'm about I feel like myself while
I'm doing it and the people on the other
side are really happy and I I get joy
from providing value to
them you can make some some sorts of
businesses work on some sort of like a
you know a lot of people have jobs which
they're not fully passionate about yeah
but you know it makes money it gets them
by to what extent do you guys think that
passion is a prerequisite for success in
Creator Creator economy land I think it
really depends what type of person you
are you know if you're motivated by
metrics if you're motivated by dollars
the message or the medium or or what
you're putting into the creative side is
not as important so you're it's easier
for you to compromise it's easier for
you to make decisions that will allow
you to be financially successful also
the yeah the passion that you have is
towards uh entrepreneurship or making
money that's a completely fine passion
to
have you know and like if the we've met
creators who say I am an entrepreneur
just happens to be that my product is
and I think that's a completely fine
thing I just think all of this is like a
process of self-discovery and
self-awareness of like if that's the
case that's completely fine you're going
to make different decisions about video
you know and that's that you're going to
make different decisions than I would
but I have to understand that I'm the
type of person that deeply cares about
the craft of the video and what it looks
like what it sounds like what goes out
to the the people on the other side I
deeply care about that and I would
sacrifice um the numbers on the screen
going up uh in exchange for for me being
happier with the
video yeah it's like this these
different approaches there there are
some people that approach YouTube or
whatever the platform is from the
perspective of a creative trying to make
money yeah and then there are others
that approach it from a perspective of
an entrepreneur trying to make money
who's recognized that there's a nation
there's like a oh I can make a faceless
YouTube channel with AI and stuff ex
that capitalizes on this High CPM Niche
kind of thing I think we um when the
term the Creator economy came I think it
was in like 2020 maybe it was the first
time I had heard it um
and it was so funny because it was the
first time I was like oh wow there's a
name for the thing that we talk about
people are calling it something that's
interesting um but I think that word
Creator got way
too used in a way that assumes that
everyone is the same like every Creator
is the same but I think the word Creator
is very similar to the word athlete like
if I said this is a show for athletes
you would say what what kind of athletes
right and think that's what the term
Creator is like I think there's like
within athlete there's tennis players
soccer players basketball players
lacrosse players and they all have
different wants needs training regimens
and there's amateurs and professionals
sem professionals all all that so the
amount of variants there are in the term
athlete I think there's that many if not
more variants in the term Creator yeah
and I think we we oftentimes assume
differently yes that's a really good
point this is partly why like
you know when like I really struggle to
make videos like how how to succeed as a
Creator in 2023 it's like a good title
and it's like oh we know it's going to
it might do well but it's like H how do
we even begin to talk to all these
people and so even the title for this
podcast episode I was thinking it's like
how to succeed in the Creator economy
okay I can get why we would title it
that but also like okay where where do
we even begin like just yeah and and
what I found and I'm curious to hear
your guys thoughts on this what I found
is that like I I really struggle to like
if someone asks me how do you succeed on
YouTube all I really know is my own
Playbook of educational talking head
videos providing value to a small niche
of people monetizing it through a course
on the back end and doing that for six
years that's a pretty reasonable formula
for success in my opinion provided you
have something some sort of expertise
something to teach in a market that's
not that's not so saturated that you
can't stand out but you guys speak to
for example Mr Beast or dream and people
like that who have made it in the
Creator economy and a completely
different way so I guess my question for
you guys is of all the people that
you've interviewed and spoken to about
this stuff do you see any like what are
the commonalities you see amongst the
creators who manage to make it
professionally versus the ones who
either just keep it as a hobby or who
who like quit after a
while uh for me it's Focus yeah I was
going to say the same thing Focus like
when you talk to you you've spoken to
Marquez Marquez brownley is someone who
is like you think about some of these
people and the amount of opportunities
that they've had to to expand into other
directions and the ones that really
remain focused on uploading videos
consistently are the ones who win like
and I I speak from a a place of um you
know experience of as we started to see
some traction I was like took a pen to
pad and I was like great now we can
launch this business and this business
and this and this and this and if we
expand like this and hire these people
then we can do that and you lose focus
pretty quickly and I would say
discipline rides right alongside that
focus and discipline like those the
ability um to have Focus discipline even
when we talked to Jimmy recently right
like Mr Beast is refocusing in on Main
Channel and Feasta bles those are the
two things and that's a lot running a
massive chocolate company and a the one
of the biggest entertainment Platforms
in the world even that is a lot like you
know even that is too much for for one
person and he has a lot of help to do it
so he's someone who's told us many times
focus on making the best next video and
the world will open up to you you know
and I I I agree on that and I think
sometimes creators eject out of that way
too soon like eject out of that Focus
too soon like I look at Colin and Samir
and although it might feel in a way to
some people maybe someone listening uh
that oh that's an established brand in
the space we are brand new we are a
brand new brand I often times think
about companies if you think about a
like a toddler right or like a baby a
one-year-old company can you leave that
alone and like allow it to fend for
itself no a six-year-old no right we six
years ago was our first upload and I
would say we really came about in 2020
so we're like three years old you know
so so you have to actually continue to
do the fundamentals of just keeping this
thing uh alive allowing it to develop um
and I think we overestimate a lot of
times like how much we can do and how
much we we should do and again I'm
speaking from a space of experience
myself of um really having to learn how
to refocus and and really having to have
discipline on like we are going to do
this we have a lot of brand building to
do um we need to be best-in class at
what we do first and maybe that's it
maybe we will never expand beyond that
but let's try and be best in class and
can we focus enough can we be
disciplined enough to be consistent MH
because that's really difficult I think
some of the top creators are all
consistent they found a way to be
consistent even though in our opinion
creative people are often not consistent
people we ourselves are not
consistent I do think that's our biggest
struggle can we focus enough can we be
disciplined enough to remain consistent
because even now that we've found a
format and we're two years in every day
I wake up and go oh I could do that how
do I make space to do that thing over
there what if we cleared three months to
do that
and things that are sort of not in what
you what probably anyone who would be
looking at us from a business
perspective would
recommend how does
this tie in okay so I I I have two
thoughts here both are somewhat gobbled
the first
is a fear that I often have that I've
had for a while and I'm only just
realizing it as I put it into words is
that what if I got a lucky break what if
you know it's it's unusual to see a
YouTuber who is relevant today who was
relevant 10 years ago outside of the
tech guys like there's very few people
who've managed to sustain that longevity
audiences are fickle audiences thingies
change like uh you know Vibes and uh
preferences change over time what's to
say that if I just continue making
videos consistently actually next year
or the year after the year after that
I'll I'll still I'll still be relevant
I'll still be around therefore should I
not focus on diversification and trying
to build a platform off of YouTube and
trying to build all these things
just in case I'm not in fact relevant I
become a hasb been two or three years
from now that to me is like uh and again
I'm going to speak from a a deep place
of experience that is like very
fear-based thinking in my opinion right
like you're there's something that
you're afraid of there of of becoming
irrelevant yeah um I think that like my
experience right now is like I've I've
somehow worked out a way to relinquish a
lot of that fear oh how'd you do
that um a mix of uh you know like being
married to a therapist uh lot of
journaling and uh slight help from
psychedelics but um I would say that
like relinquishing some of that fear
around scarcity and abundance is is what
I'll say so I've grew up in a very
scarcity mindset environment right
growing up in an immigrant household
especially immigrant I sorry especially
Indian immigrants right like coming to
America like that's scarce scarcity
mindset at you know my my parents and I
I assume that there's a lot of Trauma
from the partition um that that came
through and that is like we have to
acquire everything and hold on to it and
what if it all goes away tomorrow
because that did happen yeah right that
did happen but um as I've you know come
into this space uh I've I've started to
learn that we are in a abundant
environment and not abundant from a
dollar's perspective I could we could
not make any I think money comes into
goes and like it could all go away um
but I'm in an abundant environment
because of the people that I know and
the network that I've built and the
skills that I have I have an abundance
of skills I have an abundance uh in
network and I have abundance in just my
own ability to know how to utilize that
Network and utilize my skills so if
everything went away do I actually
believe I am the type of person that
would let all of this fall right and
that would actually let this hit you
know Rock Bottom in some way like what
am I afraid of because my worst case
scenario is not that bad and there's a
lot of people I could call along the way
a falling down that right so if I'm
operating at a space of fear it is
actually incredibly irrational because
there's nothing to be afraid of so if I
can relinquish some of that fear what
what does the world look like and this
is we were talking about this at lunch I
got to speak with a business coach um at
the um at the spotter Summit so spotter
is a company that I don't know if you're
familiar with spotter um they're a
company in the US that that works with
creators and gives creators financing uh
and we Colin and I helped co-host a
summit where we brought experts in to
talk to creators and we got to reap the
benefits of that as well because we got
to sit down with a lot of the experts
and one of the experts there was a was a
business coach and I was explaining this
to him because I was dealing with a lot
of scarcity mindset I was making a lot
of decisions out of fear I was feeling
an incredible amount of fear to the
point where I couldn't sleep um because
we had built something
and when you build something you have
something to lose and I was terrified of
losing and he said something that was
really powerful to me he was like you
have entered into a world of
abundance you are an abundant vers or
you don't know the Abundant version of
yourself you don't even trust the
Abundant version of yourself the
scarcity mindset version of yourself got
you here helped you achieve a dream yeah
so you don't trust abundant Samir to
make a decision
for you to take you to the next place
because that person is brand new that's
a stranger and he said to me the same
amount of time you need to build trust
with a stranger is going to be the same
amount of time and work to build trust
with this new version of
yourself real business coach thing to
say really good and I loved it and
that's when I realized I was like okay
there's a new version of myself that I'm
coming into but that's going to take a
long time and it's still you know it
still manifests in a space of like when
we get offered a brand deal I'm
terrified to say no terrified you know
if I say no they'll give it to someone
else and then they'll like that
experience and then they'll never work
with us because they'll only work with
our competitors and then you know and
that's that's incredibly fear-based so I
always have to take a step back and go
am I making this decision out of fear or
am I making this decision because it's
the decision that we want to make that
we are excited about that sounds fun for
us that is a decision from abundance um
I'm not saying we nailed it but like we
are we are working on that or I am
working on that personally for me I also
want to be honest and say that it's way
easier to think about dealing with
irrelevance if it were to come tomorrow
because we have found some relevance
true just being fully transparent you
know when we back in 2019 we had
negative $118,000 in our bank account we
shut down the company essentially I
moved home we had yet to be successful
and it really hurt from an identity
perspective an ego perspective
confidence I didn't know where I would
work what I would do what value I could
bring to anyone and because we were able
to find some success in 2021 and then in
2022 cross over a million subscribers
have people call us your favorite
Creator's favorite Creator things like
that to get that validation if it were
to all go away tomorrow I'd go okay at
least I can close that chapter knowing I
did it
of course I don't want to wake up
tomorrow and be irrelevant but there's a
sense of calm that comes from feeling
like we quote unquote made it after so
many years of thinking we could
never this season is Once Again being
sponsored very kindly by trading 212 now
people ask me all the time for
investment advice uh because they see
that I've made money and I've made
videos talking about where I'm investing
that money the thing that Warren Buffett
and basically everyone who's sensible in
the space recommends which is to invest
in Broad stock market index funds which
you can do completely for free using
trading 212 trading 212 is a fantastic
app that lets you invest in stocks and
shares and funds in a commission free
fashion and they've got a bunch of
features which are really helpful which
is why I personally use trading 212 to
manage a portion of my portfolio so
firstly they've got this great pies and
auto invest feature so if you're
interested in potentially getting into
investing what you can do is you can
browse the different pies that different
people have created on the platform so
you might get like a hedge font Trader
who's gone onto the platform and has
created a pie of Investments having done
a bunch of research and stuff and that
pie might be like I don't know 20% Apple
% Tesla 10% this 10% that but it
generally way more complicated than that
and you can see the performance of that
particular pie of stocks and shares and
funds and then if you want to copy that
pie into your own account you can just
copy and paste it directly in and then
you can invest any amount of money and
it will automatically split it according
to the allocation in the P so if you
wanted to just play around with £100 and
you were like okay that Pi looks good it
will split out that1 based on the
allocations of the pi which is pretty
sick they've also recently added support
for multicurrency accounts now this is
really helpful because for example if
you invest in the S&P 500 00 which is a
us-based Index Fund then you won't get
hit with all the various foreign
exchange fees if for example you're
investing from the UK like I do and if
you have an invest or an Isa account
then trading 212 also gives you daily
interest on your uninvested cash in
pounds or Euros or US dollars so if any
of that sounds up your straight then do
please hit the link in the video
description or in the show notes and
that will let you sign up to trading 212
and if you use that link you will also
get a completely free share up to the
value of £1 so it's literally free money
so you might as well so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode this is so interesting like we
were I was having this conversation with
with the the team yesterday we were um
so we're about to launch launch my book
and we were thinking
like what do we want the pre-order
bonuses to be and one of my thoughts was
let's make a $300 productivity course
and just give it away for free as a
pre-order incentive cuz that's a grand
slam offer it's like you the book for
$20 and you get a $300 course sick
amazing but then there was some push
back from the team um around but like
are we really going to give away this
$300 product like we could make money
from it like how do we know we don't
need the money like you know our
YouTuber Academy is now stopped and and
tinon our YouTube producer who we met
earlier at lunch um said guys it it
seems like with with we we're we're
we're we're having this conversation
from a place of fear like what if we
just decided to bet on ourselves instead
yes and in which case we would make a
decision that's like best for the
audience that is more from a place of
abundance and we would give away this
course cuz like why not we might as well
yeah but from a place of fear it's like
uh oh the 5,000 people who pre-ordered
the book they the warmest audience they
might buy this for $300 that's like 15K
we're losing out on like uh oh oh my God
and it starts to spiral into this
fear-based situation I would say also
like you know we are incredibly lucky to
talk to people for a living and Tim
Ferris is one of those people and he
talked about the concept of fear setting
which I think is like one of the most
important exercises I've ever heard
about I it it has stuck with me and it
is something that I actually use um
which if you're unfamiliar with it the
concept is the same way that we would
goal set we should also fear set we
should write down our fears and then
actually play them out he has a
framework it's on his website I would
recommend you check it out um but
essentially like you write down the fear
then you write down um you know how you
you essentially take it you're like all
right for example I just did a 10day
vacation and I have in the past had a
lot of fear around vacation vacation is
terrifying to me what if so here's one
of my fears what if someone emails with
an opportunity and I'm not at my
email okay well that's a even as you
hear it out loud that's a ridiculous
fear you just route it to your agent or
route it to Colin or route it to someone
else to read it and then it's okay well
what if it's an opportunity that we want
but I can't do because I'm on
vacation well if you value vacation then
you are that is a reality that's going
to happen yeah oh okay okay that's not
actually that bad yeah uh and then you
just keep going down okay how could I
repair it quote unquote well we can just
email them and see if we can do it when
I'm back right it's just like there's so
many it sounds ridiculous as you go down
and you start to realize like oh these
fears are just I haven't thought them
through yet yeah they're very surface
level and so they're they're um eating
at me because my imagination is so
powerful and I'm I'm a Storyteller
inherently so I'm able to tell myself a
completely invalid story um but if I
live it out and write it down it's like
oh okay actually it's completely fine um
um so yeah that's that's has been
incredibly helpful oh man I love the
fear setting exercise any anytime I feel
any sort of existential crisis about my
business or anything I just Google Tim
Tim feris Fear setting literally just go
through it type it all out and I'm like
at the end of it I'm like cool my
conclusion from all of this is things
are totally fine yeah I enjoy making
videos I can just keep making videos
yeah and just that's that's
it I would share some advice for you
know young creators of like
the the the way to experience some of
that is uh or what we're talking about
of like relinquishing some fear like I
think fear a lot of fear comes from um
maybe building too fast you know like
let's say you have a great Q4 yeah and
you're like oh my ad rates are up the
channel is exploding this is amazing we
should hire three more people we should
sign a one-year lease on a uh on a
really expensive Studio we should you
know invest in all these different
things um being a a creative and being a
creative business you have to expect
some level of volatility and not just
volatility in the market you have to
expect emotional
volatility and I think emotional
volatility of like I'm in love with this
process of making videos right now it's
so fun could there be a more fun job
paired with I hate this I don't want to
do this anymore you know I don't want to
make a video today I'm not feeling up to
it I want to make one video this month
instead of four that level of emotional
volatility or just you know you have to
leave space for that and if you tie your
creativity to Too Much overhead now
you're afraid now you're like now I
can't pay people now people depend on me
now I'm going to disappoint people
that's terrifying right that's that's
when fear really starts to build up when
you're like I can't pay my rent I can't
oh my God I'm not going to make any
money because to run my business costs
so much money so yeah sure we're making
a million dollars but I'm spending 990
you know like that's that's when you're
in a scary place right and if you have
two people running the company expect
two times the emotional
volatility what is that Dynamic like
because it's it's unusual to have
co-founders like a duo in the Creator
economy I suppose there's a r and Link
um there R link U but most of them are
couples yeah like mat and
Abby I love the couple yeah for the
record like we are a
couple because that is the most searched
the most searched question question
about colere or colon inter dating uh
just see us in a frame and they assume
we like sleep in bunk beds in the same
room and the how how could we not be in
this box together um but no I have a
wife and Colin has a fiance so
unfortunately uh to to to quell those
rumors we are not doing um but you know
that said it's not different from a a
marriage you know I'm married and it's
it's not uh there's some things that are
different but it's not uh you know
there's emotional similarities to it of
having a partner uh attaching your your
yourself to someone your ability to earn
is attached to someone your ability to
express is attached to someone uh your
bank account is attached to someone like
there's so much that's attached right
our our context to other people I'm
Samir from Colin and Samir right you
know that that's that's also yeah I was
surprised when I first heard your
surname I was like oh yeah I guess
you've got a surname yeah exactly yeah
yeah and so many people call me Colin
which is so funny because they like they
look at me and they're like Colin and
Samir yeah you know like his first name
is Colin they Samir first like oh Colin
wait what what yeah so we we are like to
package yourselves uh is is a very you
know it's it's it's not an easy thing to
do and I I would say that it's um I saw
this we both saw this on Twitter but
someone said uh if if you don't want to
split the company evenly with your
co-founder or co-founders you should not
be co-founders if you don't believe that
you are providing equal value y you
should not enter into that business
together and um I think that's a really
important thing you know and you have to
believe that wholeheartedly and hold on
to that belief for the entirety of the
project um you know is like we are
equals in this project we support each
other without either of us it doesn't
exist um that's a super important thing
um I think value alignment is more
important than creative alignment of
what do we value about life what do we
care about when it comes to life because
we will spend the majority of our life
together right like you spend more time
together than you do with your
respective Partners at times yeah for
sure I mean on a day-to-day yeah we're
together for 8 to 10 hours during the
day um that's really significant you
know so yeah there's a lot of complex
Dynamics to it I don't know much of a
life without it cuz we've been doing
we've been creating together for 12
years oh that's so wholesome yeah yeah
it is wholesome it's probably why people
think we're
dating I mean even for us it's strange
or at least surpris no one thinks Rett
and Link are dating yeah we don't know
that yeah actually I guess we don't know
that I guess I've never once thought
that they were dating but I didn't think
of that about you guys some reason I
guess cuz you're cuz you're younger so
like maybe we're younger yeah I don't
know we're just more stylish than them
that's probably but you don't want to go
on record I don't want to go they have
stylist they're more stylish if I can
just for a quick second I would like to
redact
just for a quick second if I can say how
jealous I am of how stylish I think R
link are every time I see them I'm just
like they look Dynamite so okay go what
what were you saying call now I'm just
thinking about R and Link style
fashionable they are there there's only
two occasions where I've seen R and Link
the first one is in their YouTube ad for
Wix before I had YouTube premium we
written link and we made our website
with Wix and the second one was their
interview with you like I did not really
know anything I think they're very us
Centric yeah they like i' never heard us
outside of that Wick's ad and then you
you them you're like are those the guys
from the wi I was like wo these guys are
huge they've got whoa and I was finding
out about them for the first time in
your interview with them I was like Dam
this is this is a good setup there did
we answer your question what was your
question um what's it like being
co-founders oh yeah what's it like
Co yeah I don't know anything else it's
uh it's a lot of what you said you don't
you don't make 100% of the decisions
that you would make you don't spend time
100% of the way you would make it you
don't get 100 % of your identity in
public you're sharing a lot of it and uh
takes a lot of compromise a lot of uh
communication and a lot of belief that
the time spent together is uh worth it
is enjoyable and is producing now the
life that that you actually want yeah
there's all you know as a bit as in a
business you know it costs a lot of
money to run our business right now
because you know we we've gotten a
bigger student again we're investing a
lot into the business right now um but
whatever my financial ambition is I have
to double it for us right as a company
and um that's our reality right and I
think you have to that is hard and so
you have to um look at the cost benefit
and be like but the benefit of this so
heavily outweighs you know that cost
that of course I'll do it and it's not
even a question there's not even that
evaluation it's just like this is the
only way I could be doing this thing I'm
doing right now which I am enjoying
doing and I also you know there's a
moment where we cross a million
subscribers while giving a speech at
vidsummit yeah which was not planned and
a very intense emotional experience
um and sharing that moment with someone
is what to me is powerful about this
whole journey is that Colin and I can
always look at each other and go dude
can you believe this m mhm we did it or
we're doing it or we just did that isn't
that crazy and like I can say that to
Colin and he can say back to me yeah man
it is crazy and like you know I can say
that to my wife or to my brother and my
dad my mom and they can kind of be like
yeah yeah it seems It's really
impressive what you're doing that's so
cool it's like do you want to go on a
roller coaster by yourself or you want
to go on it with someone that that you
enjoy who can affirm to you that it was
scary it was fun it was everything that
you also thought in your head that
yeah and so I think that that is like
you know that that to me is like I think
life is meant to be shared I think
creative projects are more fun when
they're collaborative like I just have a
belief system that this is a
collaborative thing to do um it's more
fun to collaborate and so if we're
looking at fun as a metric which it
should be for everyone in a creative
business uh then this is more fun would
either of you ever start a couple's
Channel with your respective wives
fiance
not no shot I am I have just the amount
of exposure that I want yeah okay to my
personality to everything to thinking
about a brand yeah I find it incredibly
difficult I haven't posted on Instagram
in over two years because I can't do it
and do it just objectively what do you
mean like I can't do it I I have to ask
why am I posting that who's the audience
for this with what reason what isor this
I know that won't perform because I
understand some of these
platforms and it's just I like I need to
just focus on the YouTube channel the
business that we're building I can't
spend mental energy let alone on another
like couple's Endeavor it would be far
too much I I I enjoy like posting about
personal stuff I occasionally post on
Instagram and when I feel like it I
enjoy it um but yeah I I am this to me
like in terms of amount of recognition
we have I I feel very fulfilled in it I
feel uh like I have enough I don't I
don't crave uh Fame you know beyond the
the recognition we have right now so
when I think about that and I definitely
don't crave it in the context of my
relationship what I crave in the context
of my relationship is quality time and
that to me does not include a camera so
you know that changes the dynamic it's a
it's another person in the room it's
another you're you're you are it's
completely different um and I think like
life is very fun like traveling with my
wife and you know we just went to Italy
and just had a great time and we walk to
coffee shops in the morning like I don't
want sometimes we we go to coffee shops
or we go to dinner and you know people
sometimes more than others people come
up and you know want to talk or take
pictures and um that's like so
incredibly like to me I'm still like
that's insane that people would want to
come up and and chat luckily our fans
and the who watch our show are like
professionals you know and so they come
up and they're so respectful and you get
to have like a really cool conversation
but I wouldn't want that in the context
of my relationship you know of people
looking at my relationship and and being
fans of my relationship like I that to
me is there's nothing about that that
sounds interesting or attractive I my
answer might have been different in my
early 20s when I when I really craved
Fame uh but I think that's wrapped up in
a lot of different things and I I don't
I don't have that feeling at all anymore
yeah interesting interesting I love uh
being on this side of the mic and
looking at you and being like where's he
about to take that did I just drop
something that he is now changing his
trajectory so I've been I've been
intrigued by the idea of like the coup's
channel is a phenomenon for a while oh
so you want to do it I I'm not sure this
this is the thing I'm I'm trying to
figure out yeah this is what I'm trying
to figure out because you know I've got
a podcast that I occasionally do with my
brother we've been doing it since 2019
initially it was very consistent now
less so but it's nice cuz we just rock
up what's the what's the podcast called
it's called Uh not overthinking oh not
overing yeah SE it's it's kind of nice
good memories Good Vibes get to chat
with my brother kind of thing and it's a
fun little joint project that we do
together at one point we had episode
sponsored and we hated that because it
put a requirement on it and we got rid
of the sponsors and now it's purely a
passion project yes and so my idea for a
coup's channel is like well let's say I
were to start a couple's Channel with
someone else and it was purely a hobby
like we never there no there's never on
upload schedule it's it's just like we
talk about relationship stuff
occasionally we like reading
relationship books and it's like here's
what we learned could be kind of helpful
uh maybe a brand might sponsor us to go
stay in a nice resort for a week or some
something like that I have this sort of
like somewhat idealistic like oh it
would be fun to do this joint project
with someone else um but then I think
about it and I think about like do I
need the fame no do I need the money no
like would I be trying to make it a
commercial asset no do I can just go on
the day to the resort anyway like
regardless of whether it's free or not
you want to go to the resort and do a
deliverable with
yourfriend not not recognized as the
couple
that understands how to be a couple like
if you're trying things you know you're
reading books and you're talking about
it the perception may be that you have
it all figured out yeah or that we're
learning learning along the way um and
even if you are actually learning along
the way you know I would say the
perception may not be that my advice for
you would be if you crave it to do it
without without Distributing it for a
while oh interesting yeah like make
videos with your significant other and
just watch them back yourself with her y
maybe show a friend or family like I
think we have lost the art of uh
experimenting and practicing in private
we think everything needs to be an exp a
public experiment yeah and public
experiments uh come with a lot of just
complications they come with especially
as you are a you know recognized brand
in the space
whatever you do people are going to talk
about and be like Ali abdal launches you
know X Channel why did he do that let's
break it down seven reasons why ol up
doll you know I'm like that's going to
color some of your thinking um the
strategy of it is going to color some of
your thinking like I think you can do it
in private you know when I really we had
this conversation the other day we talk
about the start of the Colin in Sim your
channel as you know September 2016 we
never talk about the start of the Colin
in smir podcast which is essentially
what has become our entire career career
which was in 2018 when we were really
down and out having an existential
crisis cuz we couldn't make any money as
creatives and decided as almost an act
of therapy to get on mics to have open
conversations with each other because it
created a container where we sat and
looked at each other and talked about
how we felt about what was going on for
an hour or two and it was one of the
most therapeutic things that we could
have done was decide that we would just
grab my and talk to each other and that
when I think about it is like something
I'd like to do with my dad I'd like to
create that container with my dad I'd
like to do that with my wife do I need
to distribute it no I could just record
it but what I actually want is the
container I want that space yeah yeah I
keep thinking about home movies the fact
that I actually do have from my younger
years home movies shot by my mom or my
dad that were just sitting on tapes in
my house and of course when they film
them it was just to hold on to these
memories and even as I travel with my
fiance next week or I think about like
having kids I don't want to not have
home movies and home video I just may
not want to put them out in public and I
think we started the podcast that way in
a way it was like let's just record this
because it's something we're going
through something we want to do was like
putting it on a shelf not that many
people were listening to it back then uh
but now I'm so happy that we did that
and we have those those memories and and
that understand of what it was like
there's an episode that I will cherish
forever which is uh the most Hollywood
thing we've ever done it was at a time
where we decided you know okay none of
this is working but our dream is to we
were making some branded documentaries
and like our background that's what
we're passionate about that's what
brought us together was our love of
documentary storytelling and so um we
had made some successful documentaries
in the more like branded world we never
made like an entertainment documentary
and during the quibby era I don't know
if you remember this wow quibby was not
a thing here the Americans listening who
are in the entertainment business I
remember quibby it was essentially a
wildly well-funded distribution platform
that was looking for Content okay
through a series of crazy events Colin
and I got the opportunity to um create a
Sizzle reel and pitch a show with a with
a creative partner who was uh named Tom
Boyd who's an awesome Creator who had
filmed essentially Home Videos in
Atlanta living in a house with Justin
Bieber and an artist named Asher Roth
and they had worked together um Asher
Roth was like signed by scooter braa
who's Justin Bieber's manager and uh had
you know was an emerging artist in
Atlanta scooter found Justin moved him
into the house too and they all lived
together and Tom was there as like a
creative partner and was filming all of
it scooter kind of suggested to him
maybe we'll make like an MTV show about
this music house so Tom filmed all of it
and he called us and was like Hey I I
found all this this footage of like
these early days with Justin Bieber and
um this song that we wrote that
essentially saved scooters company that
then financed Justin Bieber's career
like there's this crazy story about this
time and we're like okay cool we'd love
to make a dock we're looking to make a
dock this sounds like a really good dock
and we basically got the the opportunity
to create a pitch create a Sizzle reel
and go pitch this to scooter braa and
when we went there uh to our surprise as
we're pitching the show Justin Bieber
walks in the room and there's four of us
one of them is Justin Bieber and it was
just a crazy experience the most La kind
of Hollywood trying to make it his
filmmakers experience within half an
hour of ending that meeting we we got
mics and just told the story back so we
wouldn't forget every detail and we put
it up on our podcast feed again no one
listened to it but it was just like now
I sometimes go back and listen to that
episode because it was so funny and fun
and we were laughing and it was like
what a crazy experience we had nothing
happened with that pitch it did not pan
out but that memory being captured with
no commercial intent is so pure to me
and it's so great to go back and be like
that was a time in my 20s when I was
trying different things and Colin and I
would stay up all night making these
Sizzle reels and pitches and be like
maybe this is the project that'll make
our career you know and just having
these crazy experiences and that's what
I think maybe We crave and we we mix
that up with the Desire with with maybe
justifying it through commercial
intent you know you're like well if I'm
going to film me and my girlfriend I
should probably monetize it right
because I know how to monetize video but
I don't think you need to do that yeah
that's a yeah it's a it's a a thought
process that that goes through my head
annoyingly often when whenever I do like
I was playing Diablo 4 the other day and
I was thinking oh it's such a waste of
time doing this and not streaming it
like I should stream this on Twitch
exactly like twitch is dying like
YouTube game oh I guess okay cool
I guess I stream it on the main Channel
or on the second Channel and then I
guess you know might as well restream
iio to like all the other platforms and
I suppose I can answer question from the
audience while it's happening suppose we
can record that chop it up into I just
I'm just going to sit here and play
Diablo 4 for a little bit it's okay it's
all good that like confusion around like
should this be productive is something
I've wrestled with my entire life and
still wrestle with if I sit on the couch
I'm like sitting on the couch what what
could I be doing while sitting on the C
okay I'll text people I'll text you know
uh people about ideas I'll get feedback
on ideas maybe I'll call my mom maybe
it's like sitting in Stillness is one of
the most challenging things to do or
just even enjoying something for a
moment like I'll just read this book oh
but this book Maybe by reading this book
I'll know how to write a book okay
that's good that'll justify it yeah I
found that I found that for me over over
time it's it's it's kind of annoying in
a way but I've I've been increasingly
reading fewer and fewer books each year
because
before any downtime would be spent
listening to something on Audible at 3x
speed and then I'd be making videos
about how I read 100 bucks year hold on
can we just pause on that 3x speed I
mean it depends on the narrator but
sometimes 2.5 sometimes three if it's a
really dense book 1.5 that is wild I am
like 1.25 is my Max oh you can slowly
work it up over time if you really want
to but 3x is insane I mean for for most
like non-fiction books if you self-help
books if you understand the vi you can
you can kind of get through the message
but I used to do that quite a lot and
then that would lead to these great
videos where it's like how you know how
I read how I read 100 books a year kind
of thing it's not that hard if you
listen to an audio book every 3 days at
3x speed yeah if you bump that up to
100x you could probably prob read a
million hold back um but now
increasingly like even when I'm driving
I'll often just think you know what we
just like not listen to anything or go
for a walk and hide Park and not listen
to anything like actively yeah and hard
it's hard but I think over time I'm
becoming more and more comfortable with
it which then also means I'm like oh man
I used to be the 100 books a year guy
and now I read like 25 this year oh wow
what a waste man you know that kind of
thing you know what I found to be the
most helpful uh activity if you want to
start to practice not being stimulated
by Audio or video and that sounds like
crazy even when I say it but
swimming uh I started swimming and
you're underwater in this Flow State
just with your thoughts yeah and like
the first few lengths it's kind of like
you're focused on the swimming and then
after a while it goes like huh I'm just
here underwater with no inputs I can't
speak I can't listen to anything I'm
just here yeah that to me is like the
most present it's that and playing
paddle tennis oh because when you're
playing paddle tennis if you lose focus
on the ball you're like you're going to
lose the point or you're not going to
hit the ball you have to like focus on
this green ball it's like very nice to
just be like I'm present I'm focused
yeah it's funny I think the value of
there being too of us is that I'm not
like that oh yeah you know that I can I
mean I can I always since I've been a
student I can sit and focus on one thing
for hours or I can go to the beach not
listen to music not do anything and sit
for an hour I just like have that
ability I think to like like have a
baseline that's a little bit Zen VI and
maybe that's because I'm not like a son
of immigrants and like I was not raised
in a in that type you know of
environment uh but I think it's it is
like a very like different thing about
the two of us it's also the yeah again
back to the question about co-founders
it's that's why it works right like I I
said this uh the other day in a pod that
we were talking but I I said like my job
is to create the canvas Colin's job is
to paint on it that is how we operate
okay um I bust the door into a room and
say we can do this and then I actually
don't know how we're going to do it and
then Colin walks into the room and does
it yeah right like and helps us do it
like that is that has been our
relationship for 12 years not that we
don't flow over to you know the other
side and help but that that has really
been the relationship even us being here
in London right now I was not going to
be the one to say like to push and to
buy the ticket and be like yes we're
going to London we're going to interview
all these people yeah but then once the
decision is made we can craft it sink
into it creatively turn it into what we
want it to be yeah so that that is also
like again like the the the exploration
of like value in Partnership is like you
know you have to look at the other
person and be like I
I I like deeply respect empathize
understand and
value your contribution to this in a way
that's like uh I don't know how to
explain it but in a way that's like it
would never even come into question like
it just it's not even something and I I
would say that's that differs from other
Partnerships that I've been in where you
kind of go to bed and you're questioning
the value that each person is
contributing or you're questioning like
hm is this split right am I getting
compensated enough for this is this like
if you're entering into doing a creative
project with someone like the way we do
it you that I wouldn't do it if that
ever that question ever arises in your
head I also want to add one thing to you
playing Diablo 4 and feeling guilty
about it yeah so oh no so I I was
playing it while on my walking treadmill
so I got the steps in you figured that
out there it is so I tried also play
listening to listening to an audio book
and I was like no that's too much just
those two things there was a moment a
few years back when I kind of had a
similar feeling watching shows on like
Netflix and whatnot documentaries and
things like that and feeling like am I
spending a lot of my time consuming y
here and not really creating and a
really good friend of ours who was a
professional lacrosse player that we met
during our time there still you know was
a groomsman in samir's wedding Paul Rael
uh that we've done a lot of projects
with said to me he was like no that's
part of your job
you're heavily on the creative side of
this business you need to be watching
studying relaxing at times taking in
these inputs that are a bit unexpected
like you need to be exposed to all these
things so if you're staying up late and
you feel guilty watching something or
staying up late waking up late the next
day that's okay don't don't be so hard
on yourself because try and think about
where that actually fits into your
creative process not necessarily your
the productivity side of your brain or
the productive process there's a
um a little bit different uh on the
concept of rest um there is a Tim Ferris
podcast with Jerry
Colona I cannot recommend it enough it's
about um rest breaks and doing different
things and the value of that in your
entrepreneurship okay yeah I just have
to recommend it I think it it read
defined my relationship with the rest
sick yeah I will check it out you guys
both at various points use the phrase uh
finding a format you say you found the
format which you now have what do you
mean finding the format a format is the
most powerful thing in media period like
finding a format is the whole thing in
my opinion you look at some of the most
popular shows hot Ones hot ones is a
format right Shan Evans sits across he
can explain the format well right okay
I'm going to interview someone and we're
going to eat progressively hotter and
hotter Wings right questions are hot the
wings are hotter something like that
whatever the the tagline is uh Amelia de
molenberg not to stay in the chicken
space but chicken shop date right and
when you find a format you can get
better at that format you can
collaborate within that format you can
build a team around that format you can
build a brand around a format right
formats are the key that unlocks success
in Media
um it allows for that consistency that
we were talking about earlier that's
really difficult for creatives to find
yeah but if you can find a format again
you know how long it takes you know how
much it costs right let's look at how
many you can make let's look at other
examples uh Ryan Tran the penny series
that is a format I am going to start
with a penny I can only you know get
things through this Penny and I'm going
to achieve this goal at the end of it
that is a format let look at Mr Beast um
$1 Thing versus really expensive thing
that is a format right he is replicating
a format and getting better at a format
so you know largely I think I I if you
want to make it as a Creator um there is
a you know there is an unlock which is
finding your format finding that thing
that you like to make yeah that the
audience wants and that the platform
likes and and again within that format
you can also figure out how does a SP
sponsor fit into this format where does
the sponsor fit in does the sponsor fit
in y right and so all of a sudden you
have a product the product is the format
and so if if we are you looking at media
as a business then that is what you're
building the most successful formats in
the world you know if you zoom out
American Idol that is a format right
that can be scaled replicated built upon
there can be an audience for that format
so like that is that that is I think um
what you're looking for uh when it comes
to building a career on the internet uh
as an online Creator looking for a
format and for us specifically we were
doing Vlogs we were doing video essays
and then finally when we turned the
podcast into video form that's the
unlock for us that's what worked that's
what we could handle that's what we
could build a process around we could
hire for we could get out on a
consistent basis we could get better at
doing it yeah yeah that makes so much
sense I feel like so much stuff has just
sort of clicked in place in my mind and
I'm never really had the terminology to
describe it but I guess like with my
channel I've been experimenting a little
bit with formats over the years at one
point there was I started off with Vlogs
as the format then moved to talking head
videos that are educational in 5 to 15
minutes and then experimented with more
like voiceover Vlog as the format
experimented with like long form study
with me video as the format experimented
with like me giving advice while walking
around experimented with like Matt Della
documentary style format H but really
what it always comes down to is me
talking to a camera 15 minutes and
having random come up the screen
occasionally that's the format and I
keep on thinking I keep on getting
format fomo like Johnny Harris Johnny
Harris is format gets him 5 million
views a video like oh like why
don't I do videos like that format fomo
is such a good term I like that term
I've never heard that before format what
uh format fomo what the guys at Charisma
on command do like breakdowns I'm like
oh like what if I could do a breakdown
of productivity it's such a good ter
real but um again we're not consistent
people or creative people so that's why
you have the fomo you're like I'd like
to do that over there yeah yeah yeah the
um I would say the like the alab doll
format one of the greatest things is I
can close my eyes and envision it right
that's a brand a brand is consistent a
brand is something that can be talked
about I can say oh yeah Ali abdal he's a
he's a creator that does these list
videos about productivity about
evidence-based studies you know like I
can I can talk about your brand because
you have a format um if we did a
different video every single time sure
there might be people are like I like
these guys calling in smeir they make uh
creative
videos yeah that's hard to to build and
again it's this is all coming from a
place of like us articulating what it
has taken to turn this into a
commercially successful entity not what
it is taken to be creatively fulfilled
that is a different thing um so like
finding a format in media is the biggest
unlock from a commercial perspective
that's that's the thing that can take
you do you guys get format fomo these
days all the time yeah of course what it
every time I watch YouTube Netflix
Instagram at all times I think that'd be
probably fun to make I have for fomo
with you personally yeah with your
videos I I've I think I've always wanted
to have that Avenue of like looking into
a camera and and articulating ideas and
and um things that I've learned I've
just always wanted that um and I've
never pursued it so like I have format
fomo with that I think we collectively
have format fomo with
documentary yeah Johnny Harris with the
breakdown video essay definitely have
format fomo with that I think our
interview show came from me having
format fomo uh of podcasts I I spent a
lot of my 20s listening to Tim Ferris
listening to how I built this as DX
Shepard came about listening to Dax talk
to actors like and that was like I would
love to do that you know that's that for
me is where the the interview show came
from I was like that's cool no one's
doing that in the world that I really
care about that I think is actually the
future of entertainment and
Entrepreneurship so let's try that to
what extent should should you experiment
with formats even once you found your
format that
works I think everything's like you
should always be experimenting as a
creative I think the thing about even
our podcast is what happened was we were
ex we were making these like explainer
videos on our Channel people who've been
watching for a while know we found a
format that was working which was Colin
and I sit in the car and break down you
know something about YouTube yeah and
that was a great format it was fun it
got way too hot in the car cuz for some
reason we wouldn't let ourselves turn on
the AC we thought it would mess up the
sound so we would just sweat profus in
the car it took a lot of writing and a
lot of research and a lot of creativity
that you know was was intense the post-
production really sat on Colin's
shoulders which was a lot of work and a
lot of effort um and it was hard for us
to be consistent within that format so
when we wanted to experiment with a
podcast we started a podcast YouTube
channel and we started uploading the
Colin and smeir podcast to that YouTube
channel oh yeah the col and smeir show
yeah yeah well it was called
and we interviewed we gave we did A's
first interview on that channel we did
an interview with graham Stefan we
talked to each other on that channel we
probably did 20 episodes over there and
then what we realized was okay these car
videos are working and they're good and
people like them but we can only really
make like one a month or one every six
weeks the podcast while we've been doing
that we've made once a week so that's
the format because we can do that so so
now we're ready let's bring that to the
main Channel and the views were
comparable yeah and then on some other
ones they were exceeding what we were
doing exposive on the breakdown so it
was just like you found a format that
you can be it's easier to do it's more
consistent you enjoy it yeah requires
less
post-production great yeah and so now
that's become our engine right like
that's the basis of what we do it's the
basis of the business but because we
have an engine MH we now have allowed
ourselves space to experiment a little
bit more freely so I'd say don't
experiment without an engine and don't
experiment in the engine yeah you know
if you don't if you don't have to you
should always be trying to get better
and and experiment within the confines
of like you know how to how to make the
engine better um but we also changed the
name from the colme podcast to the Colin
itsme show and that was really
intentional because as we brought it to
YouTube we started thinking about what
we were doing in the car could also kind
of be done in this new show format where
maybe sometimes there would be a guest
maybe sometimes it would just be me and
Colin maybe sometimes we would do it a
little different and so to allow for
that variance we called it the Colin and
smir show that was intentional to say
there might be a level of variation here
it might not always feel like a podcast
so let's call it a show and that that
was the decision to change from Colin
andir podcast to Colin andir show and
then there was still a lot of
experimentation and I would probably say
a lot of
identity like complications within
identity of here's two guys who you know
and I'll let Colin speak more to this
but like who set out to become
documentary filmmakers and now we have a
talk show was this what we
wanted yeah I mean I was accustomed to
feeling a sense of selfworth from
editing
storytelling even holding a camera yeah
so to then forego that for an unedited
hour plus conversation where
conversation was what was
valued it was really difficult for me to
be like oh I have to just I'm going to
shed the part of my identity that gives
me what I think like validation from
myself that was kind of scary um and I
think I've kind of fought it over the
last two years of taking conversations
and hyperediting them when we first
started yeah they were very hyperedited
stuff hyperedited I I was feeling so
much fomo of that format I was like oh
man we should totally like do a podcast
where we hyperedit everything no you
should it's well if you want to do it
sure if you want if you want to but yeah
the format
that and it was really interesting
because this was a moment of like you
know creative collaboration
that I you know I could feel was like I
was a consumer of long form podcasts
Colin was but not re not as much
definitely not in video form yeah and so
like I was a consumer of this format I I
had format fomo of this
format uh I I was really happy when we
found a talk show format I was like this
is what I want to do I could see myself
doing this for a very long time yeah you
know and still to this day I'm like I I
I've pinched me moments when we do the
interviews like sitting across from Tim
Ferris was crazy sitting across from
dream was like I love this this is
amazing like we get to have long
conversations with people that inspire
me uh and that I'm curious about that to
me seems still like insane uh that that
is our job now you know we have to fly
to London to have conversations I think
I've said it every day we've been here
like this crazy is this G we can do this
we can just the dog yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's it's amazing uh it's it's
incredible but it took a long time to
accept I would say between our our
collaboration to say we are podcasters
we are talk show hosts that is what we
do that took that took time to re
establish this identity and it doesn't
mean that's all we are that is the
format that is the engine of the
business at the end of last year we got
to experiment with a documentary we got
to spend 24 hours with Mr Beast as he
opened his first physical restaurant
that was awesome that was just me and
Colin holding cameras and then we got to
collaborate um with one of our editors
Chris who really helped us while we
continued to push the engine forward you
know essentially create this story that
we were really proud of and create this
documentary that was the type of
documentary that we wanted to make and
so the engine is what
unlocked the rest of the world to us the
the dream which was let's make this
documentary and for me I didn't feel
like I was missing out on anything like
I look back on that year and that one
project was enough to feel proud of to
like scratch that creative itch to
experiment and do something different to
do something more filmmaker and now I
look at as oh my gosh what a gift that
we get to speak to people and have a
podcast that's the engine that we then
get to experiment and I also think it is
building the craft of documentary film
making in a way because we're sitting
and learning how to ask questions how to
get to interesting conversations and
we're building trust with people and if
you really want to tell a good story you
need access you need access you need
trust you need to know how to tell an
unscripted story which is what we're
doing right now and it's what you build
when you sit with someone for 2 hours
you build that
trust that's really good oh man finding
the format it's like experiment until
you find the format once you find the
format you've unlocked your engine yes
and now keep that engine running don't
like screw the engine up because you're
like chasing the the shiny thing but you
can experiment on the side with the
shiny thing if you really want to keep
the engine going but also don't
experiment too early cuz the engine will
fall apart like build the engine make
the engine strong like without an engine
you don't have a car so like worry about
like the color of the paint
yeah um podcasts loads of people get
format fomo about podcasts because
they're like I can't believe you guys
get to do this for a living where you
sit down and talk to people I want some
of that um to what extent would you guys
recommend for someone who is completely
new to the Creator World starting a
podcast as the the thing that they do I
think uh having a podcast is one of the
most rewarding things you can do I would
decouple it from the financial reward um
this was a conversation we have tin
Ferris he talked about there's the uh
non-financial reward of having a podcast
which is the conversations and the
experience of getting to have long
conversations then there is the
performance and financial reward those
are two separate things when you first
start a podcast you should not even
think about the financial reward one of
the greatest things is that we didn't
know that as we were starting a podcast
from 2018 to 2021 really that podcast
existed at as a fun thing that we got to
do
together so the reward if you really
think about it guys who are not really
making a lot of money were spending time
every week making a podcast editing a
podcast because it was rewarding from a
lifestyle perspective from a fulfillment
perspective from just I need to have
this conversation I need to have this
format so that we can sit together and
talk about the ups and downs of what
we're going through that was rewarding
in itself so I would if you're going in
as a Creator saying I want a podcast
asked remove the monetization and just
say I'm going to do this because I want
to do this because it is rewarding for
me to do this making a podcast is one of
the least expensive things in the world
for in the creative world not in the
world but in the in the cretive world um
it's not expensive you know we we had
two mics laying around that were under
$100 um we you know you could get a USB
mic like you have right now that goes
into your laptop you you can record a
podcast on a very small
budget um and you can also edit a
podcast quickly you don't even have to
edit it you can upload it through anchor
or megaphone or like any of these
there's there's services that are free
that you can use like it is a lowcost
low friction thing you shouldn't tie a
ton of stuff to it you should just have
it be a thing that you enjoy doing and
if that turns into something amazing but
I don't think you even know if you like
it until you do 100 episodes you know
maybe 50 episodes I don't think you'll
know anything about your podcast until
you do that so leave enough space for it
to end at episode 30 yeah and what do
you think is the commercial viability of
the podcast format these days for
someone completely new completely new to
it that's hard yeah I think Discovery is
really hard yeah Discovery obviously is
difficult which is why a lot of people
have taken to YouTube because you can
use SEO and and find audiences I think
when you find an audience it can be one
of the most impactful ways obviously to
monetize because you're in people's ears
for hours at a time you know I remember
there was this time where we we built to
the point where we had like 2,000 people
listening to our podcast in probably
2019 um and that to me was like a lot
that was a lot of people I think it was
like between 1500 and 2,000 people
and we did this podcast episode where
you know we were experiencing a deep
existential crisis so I didn't know we
didn't know why we were doing what we're
doing we're very confused so I stayed up
at night one night and wrote These like
17 questions that we were going to
independently answer that would help us
kind of reestablish our why why are we
doing this and so I sent it to Colin we
independently answered them and then we
came on a podcast and answered them and
it was really fun and really nice and at
the end I gave a URL to download it at
the end the last minute and it was a
unique URL and 750 people downloaded it
in the first day wow out of 2,000 people
yeah and I was like like the list of
questions yeah okay the PDF of questions
and I was like whoa that is an
incredibly engaged
audience and that's when I realized that
having a
podcast having someone in between your
ears for an hour or two hours every week
is potentially you have them in your ear
more than you have your own parents then
you have your best friend then you have
they
are they're occupying the space in
between your ears that is so incredibly
deep that connection and so what I what
what I would also suggest is like yes
discover is really hard if you are like
a brand new Creator and you're like I'm
gonna upload a podcast that's going to
be really hard if you have an audience
okay that's you know that's why a lot of
YouTubers start a podcast it's a simpler
format um they already have distribution
people people are already interested in
them okay now they can have a podcast
but you also can figure out how to
monetize with a smaller audience in
podcast because you have such a deep
connection with them is it going to be
in sponsorship that depends on your
Niche that depends on your topic maybe
you could get a title sponsor you could
figure something like that out um but
think about that premise of like if
you're selling people something if you
have a product that's truly valuable
that's connected to the
content they're probably the most
engaged audience people who click on a
podcast and an RSS feed are some of the
most engaged I would say them and
newsletter readers yeah yeah one thing
that we um I I was looking at our kind
of internal company metrics and stuff
the other day and we track a bunch of
things and I was I was looking for
patterns and I was looking at the
podcast and the podcast has about 20
times fewer subscribers and like
similarly 20 times fewer views than the
main Channel but then I looked at the
watch hours yeah and the watch hours for
the podcast are like half of what the
main Channel is yeah and so there is
like a 10x difference between watch time
on the main Channel and watch time on
the podcast given if we control for size
I was just like wow yeah damn this
podcast is actually like you need a very
way smaller podcast to have a huge
impact on people because of the forness
of it like on our audio feed
specifically uh We've like an 85%
completion rate so you know even if
you're sitting at 30,000 people
listening to an
episode but 85% complete it yeah it's
like two hours of an hour or two whoa
right that's like whoa and they will
click no matter what you put up not they
they aren't judging it based on a title
and thumbnail they're like I trust you I
trust you here so I'm gon to click it's
a permission-based environment which is
very different from YouTube which is an
interruption based environment right I
have to create a thumbnail that
interrupts you in your feed enough that
you stop and go hm okay I'm going to
click that and then you click it and I
still have to win yeah the next 10
seconds and then I still have to win the
next 10 seconds for you to buy in right
but an audio experience is kind of like
like it what podcast do you listen to
Tim Ferris for okay if if Tim FIS has a
new episode and you don't know who the
guest is how long will you give it oh
like half an hour an hour half an hour
that's the same answer that I have I
will give it half an hour yeah who will
give you half an hour on you exactly
they'll give you 10 seconds real life
yeah yeah so I think that that is what's
so powerful about podcasting um let
alone I think the fact that the lack of
video sometimes can be to your advantage
I think it's perhaps more engaging
sometimes to just listen and fill in the
gaps in your head of where they are and
what they look like and how they're
feeling that day then to watch the video
and get all those things answered for
you you're also the friend that keeps
them company on their road trip or while
they're doing laundry or you know while
they're doing another task so it's kind
of like it's like do I want to drive
alone or would I like to bring one of my
best friends in the car I'd rather bring
my best friend of the car and that's who
you are to to a lot of people which is
so interesting in podcasting it's a
completely different relationship um but
yeah it's it's not easy it's not an easy
thing to do because it's very saturated
and and people only have a certain
amount of time and you're asking for an
hour or two hours of the time it's
significant yeah yeah
dring um changing gears a little bit you
guys have a newsletter business as well
called the published press yeah which
was only when you guys were interviewing
me in La that I I realized that oh
that's a really clever name because it's
like press published but like reversed
and also it's like like whoa that's
that's really clever I I can't believe I
come
that um what's the story behind the
newsletter business and why did you
decide to start a newslet
business yeah so I I think um and what
is a newsletter business just for people
who might not be familiar with the
publish press yeah I mean our business
is uh content and sponsorship that's
like to simplify it we produce content
and we get relevant sponsors to sponsor
that content that content happens in
audio form in video form and now in
written form um that's like the simplest
version of it right and you look at um
what the content stands for like what is
the the the product that we are creating
um well a lot of what we're doing is
building a very hypers specific audience
that's interested in a c certain topic
um which is the creator economy and The
Business of creators so as we started
producing you know the podcast uh as a
video podcast we were still having
hiccups in the process and figuring it
out but at maximum we were like we can
make one of these a week you know that's
that's maximum for us is what it felt
like we can make one really good one a
week um and we were aware we had a
conversation with Alex liberman who was
the one of the founders of morning Brew
we had a nice call with him talked and I
was like I'm curious about newsletters
because I think the audience that we are
building spends time in their email
inbox like we're building a professional
audience they care about this profession
of being a Creator and a professional
audience spends time listening to things
and reading things and we're making
YouTube videos so that attracts kind of
the aspirational Creator and we break
our audience up into aspiring creator
career Creator and Creator industry okay
the aspiring Creator is you know the
Creator who knows how to make videos has
probably made some videos that have hit
or you know trying to figure it out and
um they hang out on YouTube they get
their education from YouTube right um
the career Creator is someone who is
making an income and trying to figure
out how to progress in their career
trying to learn from other career
creators trying to um figure out how to
make more money trying to understand the
career looking for you know a sense of
community they're feeling isolated um
and then you go to the Creator industry
those are people who want to work with
creators they want to join the industry
they want to understand creators more
each one of those um categories of
audience um has different wants and
needs and requires different things and
also hangs out in different places as I
mentioned that visual to me is like a
pyramid the aspiring Creator is the base
of the pyramid um they hang out on
YouTube big big audience that's a big
audience it's on YouTube we're going to
a ton of that audience and we need to
provide them value right the career
Creator is also on YouTube but they also
open their email inbox right the uh
Creator industry probably mostly opens
their email inbox right so now where do
we provide content in this pyramid
YouTube podcast inbox so that's that's
that was the thought right is like where
do we provide value where do we catch
our audience where they already exist
because our exercise and these are
worksheets that are you know going to be
in our course or that we've already
built for our course it's like how do
you study where your audience is and
that's what we realize audience is in
the email inbox so we wanted to do it we
we met with Alex
liberman and talked to him about it
understood like okay this is creating a
good newsletter is similar to creating a
good show right you have to get the
right people involved you have to uh
have people help you in in the way we
wanted to do it we wanted to do
something similar to morning bre which
was hey can we tell three Creator
stories and can we do that multiple
times a week now we've gone from okay we
tell one story in podcast form but we
could potentially tell six stories in
written form a week maybe nine could we
do that how could we do that and so Alex
introduced us uh to someone who was
leaving morning Brew at the time named
Josh Kaplan uh who came on as a
consultant and helped us just figure out
how to spin it up how do we how do we
make a newsletter who do we hire what
does it look like and what we did was we
we brought on a writer and we ran it
internally we built it and ran it as an
internal newsletter at our company to
say what is this process like is this
good is this
valuable is this anything you know is
this a thing we want to do so we did I
think maybe like two and a half three
months we did it just internally a
little over two months yeah I think what
we realized too is that in our company
Slack started to bring in more voices
people who consume different parts of
the crater economy than we do people who
focus on gaming or fashion and realizing
that within this slack Channel where
everyone was sharing news that they were
seeing throughout the day that we were
building something really valuable that
if people could have access to
essentially a curated version of this
that can kind of be the newsletter and I
think we started to realize that in
those two months of development by
bringing in writers adding them to the
slack Channel and that's where we were
like oh that's where this value really
is we can only tell so many stories on
our YouTube channel we can only
interview so many people because we
primarily interview people whose content
we watch or listen to and that's going
to be capped Y and this was a way to see
a much more holistic picture of what's
happening with creators that we felt was
valuable that we could distill to other
people we talk a lot about the term
value prop extension so you're like what
is your value prop as a creator
and what is an extension of that value
prop so you know for us it was education
or it is education right education and
curation I would say I would say
education curation and articulation we
articulate what's happening in this
industry right so those those three
things are value propositions um
education okay how can we extend that
courses we can make well
articulated well curated online courses
that you could buy okay that's a
Direction for us um education curation
articulation we can write about the
greater economy so that was the
extension right and so like those were
the two things we really looked at those
are good extensions we could do events
right we could do events that's that's
pretty good but that's that's hard we
don't know how to do that um and so
that's where we said okay there's some
choices here merchandise is a choice but
is a t-shirt an extension of those three
things I just said not really right it
it does represent community and identity
which is a part of our value proposition
but not it's not what we lead with so
that's where like newsletter made sense
to us we can extend our value prop
through this newsletter and that's why
courses make sense to us those two
things are extensions of our value
propositions um and so as we ran it
internally for a while then we said okay
I think this is ready then we released
it to a trusted group like a couple
hundred people and basically asked the
question is this valuable and the answer
was yes and largely I think because of
the curation there was so much happening
someone tell me what
matters you know what do I care about in
the space if I'm a graduating college
kid how do I learn quickly about what's
happening in the Creator economy oh I
could subscribe to this newsletter and
learn right so it's like it just felt
right and so then you know we we um
released it we ran it we we ran it for a
few months without any sponsorship just
ran we acquired um you know thousands of
readers and then um we started getting
sponsorships and then we also realized
uh at some point that this is its own
company it we have our own writers for
the company it needs to build its own
culture it's uh it's its own thing and
we're in the process of that now it's
spun into its own company and you know
the original team that helped us and
brought on we brought on as consultants
or partnered into it um we we own it
with uh with two other people and um
that is uh a whole experience in and of
itself of building another content
coming along what we do um but it
follows the same thing we know make
content get sponsors yeah like those are
the things we know how to do so we we we
are in that when I talk about courses
although it's a value prop extension
it's a different business you know that
I've talked to you at length about
courses and I'm very overwhelmed by this
new business um and ready to get into it
now that we have these engines that
we've built but um courses is a new
business it's a completely different
business model merchandise is a new
business model these are all new
business models but creating content and
selling sponsorship is a business model
we are familiar
with that's so interesting yeah I
guess value prop extension yeah I guess
for us it's the thing that we're good at
is creating content and selling courses
and so when I speak to people who
struggle to make courses I'm like guys
it's so easy but I'm forgetting that
like we've been doing it for a while
like I've been making courses since like
2013 like I've been doing this for a
while 10 years of figuring that out yeah
you're you're also Al good though at
like taking uh Concepts and uh boiling
them down into simple like well
articulated videos so I would say the
course thing makes sense but then us
trying to build our own stationary brand
which we tried to do last
year adjacent yeah adjacent it's like
one thing I'm exploring now is could we
build our own productivity
app which feels like valy prop extension
in that we help people be more
productive and build a life they love
it's like cool instead of promoting
apps that we don't own can we promote an
app that we do own turns that making an
app is really freaking hard everyone
spoken to like bloody is really hard I'm
like okay well if we made a $5 a month
app for us to make anywhere near the
amount of money we could make on a
course it would require like hundreds of
thousands of users MH it's almost not
worth it like why are we trying do you
invest in a productivity app do you have
a long-term partnership with a
productivity app that's what I would
explore as a Creator it's like do you
need to own it do you need to be in the
software devel vment or app development
business like probably not probably not
right I'd love to be a minority
shareholder in a other productivity app
that I genuinely use that's available to
you after this you'll get emails from
people and you can evaluate those and
maybe you can bring on someone on The
Venture side to be like hey you know
what we're going to set aside half a
million dollars or $250,000 and we're
going to make $50,000 investments into
startups right and then you can you can
scratch that itch of like I want this
productivity app but let me get the
people who are committing their life to
software development let me not pretend
like let's not pretend like I'm going to
do that like are you ready for 10 years
of learning that everything takes like
10 years so one one one question I was
asking myself uh when journaling the
other day was what would I do if I knew
I wouldn't fail and on that list was I
build a productivity app but then I
asked myself what would I do even if I
knew I would fail yeah and on that list
was definitely not building productivity
CU I was like absolutely hell no like if
I knew it was going to fail why the hell
would I build a and I was like ah hang
on that's interesting that's interesting
yeah even if I knew I would fail like
one one thing that was in both lists is
I just really like the idea of building
like a stage show like a oneman stage
show like Darren Brown me J kind of
Vibes and that would be super fun as a
bit of a side side project even if like
it completely failed because I would
want to combine like magic and music and
like mentalism mind reading type stuff
with like message I dabble yeah you know
used to do closeup magic at parties and
balls at University C tricks and
you know wow B over there I would love
to come see that show yeah so that feels
really fun and that that's lit far
underneath me of like oh this would be
really cool but I'm also not imagining
it's going to be like a particularly
commercially yeah legit thing it's just
like okay cool that's a bit of a a side
Hustle but I like this idea of Valley
prop extension how how do you square the
newsletter with the whole Focus thing
cuz it's not you're splitting your focus
between like not just focusing on the
the format that
works I think we have sacrificed Focus
yeah to get it off the ground there's no
doubt in my mind yeah that the fact that
we've done what we've done over the past
couple of years while also launching
that surprises me and I think there will
be a period there is going to be a
period now of getting focused back as we
build it as its own company truly uh
with someone at the helm who probably
wakes up every single day and is like
this is my soul Focus you know not just
part of our Focus part of our focus is
obviously heavily on what we're doing on
the colon and smir side part of it is
what's happening with the published
press yeah I think uh as creators like
we're very excited because we are
creators the term is like about making
things it's bringing ideas to life right
and that's not just video so like I
think we are great zero to one guys
right now like we can come up with an
idea and and really push it from zero to
one and because of our distribution now
we have an accelerant attached to that
zero to one right which is great but the
1 to 10 needs to be done by a seasoned
person and
your role in the 1 to 10 is to continue
building your distribution you know it's
called the publish press that was
intentional so that it could scale not
the Colin Samir ex Colin and Samir
everything we do with Colin and Samir
unscalable the day we don't want to do
it it's over it's an unscalable project
and that's okay but what we want to do
is build scalable projects alongside it
right and so the publish press is a
scalable project um and that requires
team and operators to do that scaling
right and and alongside the scaling we
have to continue being the accelerant
which is we have to build our show we
have to come on shows like this we have
to be Colin and smeir who own the
company the publish press right and if
we can be that alongside seasoned
operators who can operate it and hire
people and have a company culture there
then we will find success um but the
push poll is going to be can we let go
enough to allow that team to develop on
their own without us controlling it and
being like that line didn't work why did
and we are those type of guys right we
are those guys who scrutinize everything
um that goes out can we let go of the
grip a little bit and play our role in
this and allow the team to play their
role um and so I think like as I look
forward it's like there's a lot of zero
to ones that I'm really excited about
those are hard and they will sacrifice
focus on what we're doing but you also
have to know that you're not the person
to go from 1 to 10 you are not there's
no possib way you have to be the Creator
I need some advice one thing we are
considering doing is launching a daily
newsletter called a daily productivity
okay so I bought the domain daily
productivity like daily stoic exactly
like daily dad like fully inspired by
Ryan holiday we spoke to Billy and
Dawson from his team when we were in
Austin Ryan's so good and we were like
okay that's really cool uh I had um Alex
lman on the Pod like last year talked
about morning Brew is like that's an
interesting model it's super inspired by
what you guys are doing at the public at
at the published press
and the idea being like can we do daily
stoic but like the productivity version
where we give you a productiv an
evidence-based productivity tip or an
idea in your inbox every morning for
your consideration or something like
that where it's not tied to my name
maybe for at the started daily
productivity by Ali abdal or something
but like over time we lose that thing
and try and build its own thing around
that
thing what what do you reckon what are
the thoughts that you'd be like what
what sort of questions would you be
asking what's how would you approach
that how how would you write the content
batch like would you write 365 before
you launch it uh probably not um we are
thinking we'd write seven and pilot it
for seven days um with our audience and
see what happens and
then four weeks from now decide are we
actually going to do this cuz we're in a
bit of a we're not sure if we want to do
this stage right now I definitely highly
recommend what we did with keeping it
internal pilot it internally for like
start with just staff okay and I would
think like friends yeah 60 to 90 days of
piloting at a minimum yeah at a minimum
but and I would also in that because
what we do is topical what we do is let
me tell you the latest let me tell you
what matters that's that's hard right
and like daily stoic is awesome because
I can read it three years in a row in
terms of the book not not the newsletter
but like that's one of the greatest
things um I would write 365 before you
launch because what you're doing is it's
not it doesn't it's not tied to date
right no it's not yeah the ones that we
wrote we couldn't
couldn't so we we were writing and they
couldn't but I would write I would just
think about it as like we're going to
spend three weekends writing 365 of
these and once we because then you're
happy with it you're happy with the
project and then it goes
out like decouple the production from
the
distribution because the overwhelming
thing for me is writing 365 and that is
what you're
doing with the what's it called the
daily daily productivity daily
productivity what you're doing with that
is you're building a ritual so if that
doesn't hit my inbox at 9:00 a.m. or
whatever the time it is you've you've
my ritual I don't know if you
swear on this podcast but yeah but uh
like you have you have messed up my
ritual um and you have to think about
like ritual based content is about the
ritual I might not care about what you
sent on day 120 but my ritual is to
click it open and drink my coffee and
I'm habit stacking right to to quote
James Clear there so you're building a
habit for me so how do you ensure that
you're going to hit me every day at the
exact same time the way I would do that
is write it all be happy with it and
then distribute
yeah why 365 why not like
90 because I thought you wanted to do it
every single oh oh oh why 365 yeah so
why would like why why not write 90
issues and then launch it if we're happy
with the 90 and then figure it and then
build build the tracks as the train is
I think it depends on your relationship
with the content yeah like I
really I I would struggle if on day 92 I
didn't like what was written and it was
written by my team or like and it went
out and I had to rush it and I had to
make something that I didn't like I
would really struggle with that and so
that's why I say I would want 365
written before it went out um but if
you're kind of like I give it space to
be
like I know that some of them are going
to be 10 out of 10 and some of them are
going to be three out of 10 but in
aggregate the whole Project's going to
be an eight out of 10 then you know
maybe you can do that um but I I don't
know how to get someone else to do that
work that that I'm 100% happy with so I
have to have a different relationship
with with a lot of the stuff you may
also want to make sure you have an
understanding of what is that one out of
10 newsletter send and what is the you
know five out of 10 or whatever it is so
that you can actually space them out
appropriately yeah instead of just you
know like oh winging it yeah like
running out getting close to running out
then all of a sudden you may send a 5
out of 10 a 6 out of 10 a 7 out of 10
for multiple days in a row yeah uh and
then your quality goes down but I think
you can do the internal thing first
right and be like is daily too much or
is daily just right you know you have to
answer that question too as a consumer
yeah so I think you have to answer some
of those questions first and then you
can make the decision on which want to
do the project but I would batch produce
it that's good but it sounds right for
your brand obviously like it's a prop
extension also is it a newsletter is it
a text oh is it an SMS oh right project
through Community or something like that
maybe I want it as a text yeah maybe
maybe that's the option maybe my
productivity um doesn't allow me or
doesn't I'm not good at opening my email
first thing in the morning or I just
want to clear my inbox I don't want more
clutter in there so give it to me
somewhere else yeah maybe it's uh what
Ryan did with daily stoic in podcast
form and you know you can click a date
and hear you say it I don't know I I
would really look at like the
distribution of it and what's like what
do you like from the distribution but
just think about those two things you
know distribution being they're
decoupled and they're different and you
have to understand both um yeah are you
glad you have a newsletter
business yes yeah I I think uh based on
what I talked about with um permission
and Interruption um it's a permission
based environment the people there have
given us permission to be in their inbox
they open it when we send they click on
stuff that we recommend um that is a
group that I feel like I have a deeper
understanding of that I have uh a depth
of connection with because of the
permission they've given
us on YouTube it's harder right because
you're like I have to interrupt you you
know but I kind of wish I could be like
just just just watch whatever I put out
yeah you know but that's not the case
and um the newsletter format kind of
allows us to to have this perion per
based environment and if you don't want
that anymore if you don't give us
permission anymore you just unsubscribe
and it's and it's done so the people who
are there who are opening it that to me
is like a very core group um yeah and I
also think it's like it's been a really
good lesson in scaling yeah I'm happy we
tried something new like it has it own
it has its own set of challenges that
would not come from having a YouTube
channel and it's interesting to learn
about how to build a different type of
slightly different type of
product and business and to experience
actually even the highs and the wins of
like launching cool things with it or
seeing people tweet about it and
realizing oh I didn't I didn't have much
of a hand in that newsletter send that
day it's pretty cool that like something
came out of our camp that people are
resonating with that's really
interesting I think also like uh we were
with Matt from yes Theory who doesn't
watch YouTube doesn't have Instagram
doesn't really have social media but
reads our newsletter and he said to us
yesterday he was like that's how I keep
up with this world and I was like that's
that's so great and there's some people
who I've gotten messages from who are
like you know at UCLA or in in college
who are like this is how I am learning
about the job I want to have and to me
that's the coolest possible thing and
take it a step further there's people
who have been hired because of the job
listings we put in there there's
creators who hit us up and they're like
hey man I just hired an editor who
applied through your newsletter that's
crazy like that to me is transformation
and transformation is very energizing
and fulfilling as a Creator when you
know you've trans formed
someone why is going viral a bad
thing I think it's not a bad thing it's
only bad if you take the wrong
indicators from it I think it was MKBHD
who said the best thing that never
happened to me was having an early video
go viral if you have a video that goes
viral it's your first one or your second
one and the process was terrible you
didn't like it but then you just take
that as an indicator of that's exactly
what I should do you're going to find
yourself in a life that you don't like
so I think it's just about having the
understanding of the lifestyle you want
if and when virality comes yeah I I
think sometimes uh virality turns you
into someone who is uh constantly
seeking that
outcome of virality and um I think the
the thing to seek is the process right
and so that that's that's my opinion of
like I think as creators we should be
seeking a a better more enjoyable
process not necessarily the outcome like
the outcome is a byproduct of that
process um and so if we're just chasing
the outcome and I'm speaking from a
space of experience the DOP mean head of
going
viral is one of the most intoxicating
things ever how did you guys feel off to
your Mr Beast video because that was
like two million views in like two days
which one the the most recent one the
interview oh I mean the thing is you get
to a point where you can look at what
you're creating and understand what you
know the you understand the the the
distribution perspective of that I think
we felt some of our on the production
side like we we had wished we had you
know asked a few more questions we wish
we had taken some different angles and
like so there was some of it where we
sat down as a team and we were like how
can we do a better job of prepping that
that's what we took away from that I I
assumed that you know there would be a
large audience for that you know that's
not that's not a surprise the bigger
Rush was 5 years ago when we made a
video essay about David DOI and he
shared it on Snapchat and it blew up up
like crazy and you just comments are
coming in and you think this is it we
made it this is the moment Everything
Will Change I I think the you know one
of the the rushes for me came from you
know when we did our interview I felt
like it was a great conversation and I
was like that was a rush when we did our
interview with dream it was a rush when
we did our interview with destroying we
found places and avenues and uh learned
things that was like a total rush we did
our interview with Tim Ferris was a rush
and like all of those have different
metric numbers next to them from a
distribution perspective but process
wise some of those were really really
fun and I felt like we were really
prepped and we um really just nailed
what it meant to be Colin and Samir in
that conversation same with the try guys
I think that was another one that felt
really good and so some of those those
to me feel really great but the virality
of them is a separate thing and that is
not entirely up to us it's it's up to
how the audience receives it yeah you're
focusing on what you can control yeah
yeah which is the process and showing up
consistently that's the more succinct
way of saying what I just said yeah
yeah I think this is um I've I've
recently been reading the practice by
Seth Goden oh such a great book um I
highlighting the hell out of it I'm just
like oh my God this is the advice I need
right now where I'm having format foro
I'm like oh you know maybe I should make
more Johnny Harris videos it's really
hard to make a Johnny Harris video and
like I've been trying Johnny Harris is
Johnny Harris because he knows how to
make Johnny Harris videos yeah and then
even speaking to you guys over lunch
where I'm like yeah I don't if I should
just continue with my three videos a
week that are chill and nice and fun to
film and I enjoy making them or do
something completely different for the
sake of chasing some numbers it's like
the the answer is obvious as I even as I
say it yeah it's the process rather than
the result yeah um you mentioned
something in a video around like 12
lessons from 12 Years on YouTube uh you
mentioned brand is more important than
reach in the long term what do you mean
by that uh reach what we're talking
about here views is many times filling
space on these platforms if you think
about Tik Tok shorts Instagram
reals it's so quick the the amount of
time that your video will come in there
capture someone's attention and then
they swipe and they move on you are
potentially just feeling a void of space
for a quick jolt of entertainment or
whatever it is the person who watched
your video may not remember who you are
the value that you bring enough to come
back again and again like that would be
a brand so we're recommending and urging
creators to think about how they can
connect with people consistently over
time in a way so much so that they can
can have a brand that people will
remember and we've been making uh comps
to Severance which is such a great show
I haven't seen it oh it's phenomenal
it's amazing right and yet it hasn't
been on the air in over a year right but
when it comes back I'll watch it because
the brand of the show is remarkable and
it's so good that I'll wait for that and
as a Creator you want to try and do a
similar thing you don't want to feel
like you have to upload every single day
right yeah it's like back in the day
when Sam C was making videos it's like
every six months oh Sam CER video just
dropped and everyone just flu to it in
the sort of travel I don't even know if
Sam CER has uploaded in the past year
but if someone told me Sam CER was
working on something I would think it
was premium yeah yeah when you say sam
CER I see a sunset in my head a beach
cinematic super attractive guy doing a
back flip he he actually hit me up on
Instagram like two days ago Sam's great
we worked with Sam on a on a project a
couple years ago he's awesome yeah he's
so cool like honestly you know what's
upsetting is that he's that attractive
and that cool
you know yeah I know it's really unfair
it's just you can't have all of it some
has a brand so he can take breaks right
this was about BR like a paid thing with
DJI and it's like oh it's just such a
good I'm going to watch it anyway even
though I know it's an trades on like
Brands trade at a premium yeah you know
I don't know how many views Sam Colder's
videos get I don't but if I was working
at a brand I would want a Sam CER video
yeah right talk video is sick great if I
was working at uh yeah like DJI I'd be
like yeah I want a Sam CER
not because of his but because of the
brand Association yeah we talk about
this concept of
Singularity that Sam CER is singular for
a lot of people and for a lot of Brands
DJI might not want just any Creator want
want Sam CER and that goes for Brands
too right Coca-Cola doesn't want you to
just want any drink they want it to be
Coca-Cola and so we urge creators to
think about that how do you get to a
point where you're singular you're
irreplaceable and we have a worksheet
for that
oh in our course nice that we're
building yeah that you're building
when's it going to be released uh I
would think September is safe um yeah
September is safe yeah September is a
safe bet like we are title for it
yeah we have many yeah many titles for
it uh we have a whiteboard full of
titles but we're we're closing in on it
I think like we're very uh confident in
the curriculum of it and very confident
in the worksheets like I think it's a
it's a course that's self-discovery like
you will discover a lot about yourself
you discover a lot about your business
um and you'll come out of the other side
being prepped to figure out how to turn
what you're doing creatively into a into
a product into a business right I'm sold
yeah there you go that was the sales
pitch that sounds great sign me up yeah
um yeah brand brand thing is interesting
like I I feel like there's a lot of
people these days who especially with
the Advent of short form content there
are millions of followers millions of
views and completely broke like is that
a pattern that you guys see as well mhm
mhm yeah I think not only uh you know
completely broke or not it's like
millions of views millions of followers
but could not fill a room if they had an
event you know like nobody really
cares um and I think that's because the
the the platforms have done this really
smart thing right and largely led by Tik
Tok where it was like okay people are
here for creators that is pretty
volatile creators come and go they could
leave they could like so what Tik Tok
showed everyone is that the platform
could be the
Creator when you say I'm watching Tik
Tok you are watching Tik Tok there's
very few people who go on Tik Tok and
say okay I go on Tik Tok I search Ali
abdall now I'm watching ol abdall right
no it's I'm watching Tik Tok I'm
scrolling the for you page so Tik Tok is
the creator yeah you take the top 10
creators off of Tik Tok Tik tok's still
Tik Tok it's still enjoyable yep
right and so YouTube I I believe you
take the top 10 creators off YouTube
it's a very different place um but
YouTube was looking at Tik Tok and
saying hm you know not only this is what
the the younger generation likes but
it's also a it's a safer bet for a
platform yeah because if you stop making
your videos is that going to change the
shorts feed no you just replace it with
something else yeah people may not even
notice on a short form feed yeah no
one's going to be scrolling be like
interesting there's no Alia haven't seen
one those in a while so like the feed is
the Creator and that's like a really
safe bet for the platforms but as the
Creator you have to recognize that you
are
not really building your own individual
brand you playing into the feed and you
might be rewarded for playing into the
feed but you were playing into the feed
it's not to say some creators aren't
doing it and building careers and
building communities on short form
content but I think it's way more
difficult yeah and they're stick there's
some creators who are sticking out
dramatically and then they're they're
typically though they're like building
into a more you know kind of sticky
format or something that gives them
length like podcasting is is common if
you build um a large audience or moving
over to long form YouTube videos like
long form if you can make it in long if
you can use your short form videos to
build your long form videos then you're
in a good
place if you guys were let's say you
decided that today you were going to
start a YouTube channel for example
or what would be your balance of long
form short form videos and how would you
go about YouTube versus Tik Tok versus
threads versus all the all the 10
different options we have for posting on
platforms these days like if you were
trying to build this crat economy career
I can only speak from a completely
biased perspective which is that I enjoy
making long form content for YouTube
because I enjoy watching YouTube yeah I
would probably test uh formats on shorts
because I think you need to practice a
lot and you need to find your voice and
I think shorts created a lower barrier
to entry like when you say get going uh
when I think about that the easiest way
for me to get going would be to make
short form content right but I think you
have to have the understanding that you
are doing that to find your voice for
long form content at least for me I
would be like I'm going to make shorts
for a while to test the market test the
audience find a group of people
interested in the subject matter and
then give them long form content that's
what I would do nice uh Colin one thing
you said that in one of your videos that
you're not working on a YouTube channel
you're working on yourself what do you
what do you mean by that um I think that
with everything obviously we've been
talking a lot about process while we've
been here and it's not the final video
people see the final video right and
maybe they spend 30 minutes 40 minutes
with it but for me that was potentially
a month of my life
so I need to think about how I spent
that month did I enjoy it so with every
video I'm thinking about the process and
then trying to adjust
you know and that's where I think it is
this process of like every video every
experience as a part of this channel is
an opportunity for me to reflect on
myself and how I enjoyed it how I showed
up in that video was I proud of
that right I think it's also a lot about
like how you choose to spend your time
like we choose to spend our time making
videos that then go out and are you know
publicly judged or
validated you know like why do
I I always think about this like why do
I do this and I think whatever you're
doing whether it's making videos or
entrepreneurship like it's all a process
of self-discovery why am like who am I
that I care about this so much that's
what you're figuring out with every step
of the way you know like next year am I
going to want to upload more videos or
less videos and what does that mean
about me do I want to make more money
why do I want to make more money what do
I care about what's my value
system I'm not going to care about
everything we do equally yeah
right you're going to care about things
differently and even the way you care
about something is going to change yeah
right it'd be impossible for me to say I
care equally about like our Discord our
newsletter our interviews our Twitter
account our Instagram
account right that's all going to
fluctuate and and I have to take stock
of that and make decisions based off of
how I
feel if you guys won the lottery and you
had 100 million in the bank What would
about the way you spend your time if
anything I I don't I think I would have
coffee with more people and feel okay
about that like feel okay about um
spending a little bit more time and
moving slower um I think that would be
one big thing I I know that's so
achievable but like this exercise is I
think whenever I do this exercise it's
to reveal like what is achievable in
your life right now cuz at least for me
most of what I want is very achievable
just have to like uncover it um I think
it would just be like time I would I
would treat things um I would give time
to more things like I would move a
little slower in my creation um so that
I could have more time for other things
I would also build a recording studio so
that musicians could come in and record
and I could just be there that's been
one of my dreams for at some point when
I settle down and have a studio space I
want to have like a creative campus
somewhere like out in nature where
people can come and create things yeah
that would sick I think we're just
describing Rick rubin's Shang now yeah
but I have a friend who's doing it in ta
New Mexico he bought a bunch of land and
he's building a recording studio there
and he's doing like artist residencies
and like that's really popular as the
writer writers go there to hang out yeah
writers go there and so he's doing that
as well his writers who are coming and
like to be around that to be a part of
that to enable that to absorb that like
just creative people exploring creative
things and specifically music for me is
really important and I haven't gotten to
be around it since I was in high school
I'd love to be back around music so
I I would just spend my time differently
that's it you know like you just spend
your time on things that are are
enjoyable and exciting but I am a
creative person I enjoy creating I would
always create I'm not creating you know
purely because I think it's a good uh
financial decision I think there's a lot
easier ways to make money than what we
do so if it was about you know
generating money I would do something
different I think I would open up a
budget for myself friends and particular
and my family to fly either like first
class or private to come see me or for
me to go see them and try and minimize
the Gap yeah of time that we don't see
each other and make it really
easy that's cool would you continue to
do the the show the Colin andir show
100% Yeah question yeah that would be
you had or if we both said
no this thing no we hate each other yeah
yeah without a doubt I mean like my
answer is like so vehemently yes because
the people that we meet like like I said
what I would do is like have coffee with
interesting people I I have a formula
and a format to do that that allows for
um you know a Ryan holiday to come and
sit with us for three hours like I we
have that so it's great yeah like that
is that is great I would do more of it
and some of it I would do off the
mic back in the day the advice that you
would often hear about growing a YouTube
on YouTube or podcast whatever is the
jab Jab jab right hook thing of like
give away loads and loads and loads of
free content this is the the Gary Gary
Gary V model a jab is giving away free
content and you do Jabs for like 50
times before you land a right hook the
right hook is the ask the selling
something and so the whole vibe was
spend ages building an audience with
free with free content you build an
audience of people who know like and
trust you and then when you decide to
sell something there will be people who
are willing to buy
it I feel like that formula is sort of
changing but I wonder to what like what
are your guys views on how long should
you spend building and creating free
stuff before thinking about monetization
when you're saying free stuff are you
saying ad supported stuff oh yeah I mean
like videos on YouTube for example that
just have AdSense behind them before you
start selling a product uh before you
start selling a product yeah for example
yeah so that depends on if you have a
value prop extension that is a product
right like or like it could be a digital
product could be a physical product but
like one of the greatest things about
YouTube specifically um that is
completely insane is that you can just
create content and if you create a
certain type of content you just
magically receive a check every month
and I don't want to oversell that that's
hard to do but if you're that type of
Creator who can do it that's the highest
margin creative business that I've ever
seen what what you don't have to get on
the phone with an Advertiser you don't
have to read a contract you don't have
to negotiate a rate all of a sudden
you're making stuff and a check comes
that's crazy you know like you really
think about that and like to me me
sometimes I think it's crazy when
creators complain about AdSense or or ad
rates it's like it's not in our control
like this is this is not our platform
it's we you know yes we make up the
platform but like we don't I don't know
this thing is crazy that they just pay
us and some of the ad rates are
ludicrous that you see you're like oh my
God it's also the only game in town yeah
for the most part there aren't any other
platforms who are offering splits like
this at rates like this I think there's
some tangibility that we can talk about
of like when should you sell something
and you know what we look at as like
views from subscribers returning viewers
like do you have a healthy Community are
they actually coming back are you just
really good at making titles and
thumbnails that are reaching a
completely new audience every time you
upload um I wouldn't sell something if
you are reaching a viral new audience
every time you upload you could have you
know five million views of video but
it's new audience and they're kind of
there just for entertainment they don't
want to buy something from you but that
could turn into a great sponsorship
business and a great advertising
business um if you have like 10 to
20,000 people who are coming back every
single time you're like okay there's
something here do I have an extension of
my value that I can offer to them but
it's going to be subjective like again
back to the athlete thing that's like
you know it's tough to say it's based on
the
athlete nice final question um what are
you guys working on for the next six
months up until the end of the year we
are working on our course that is like
one of the biggest things that we are
working on um I a bunch of interviews
we're here filming interviews we're
working on you building our engine and
solidifying our engine and and making
sure that we have great interviews and
content on our channel that provides the
value that we've promised that's like
number one right that always has to be
number one on your priority list as a
Creator um and then you know number two
as we feel like the engine is getting
more stable is is building out these new
value prop extensions continuing to
build out the publish press newsletter
with the team that's there um and
building this course which is a
completely new business completely new
thing a completely new cycle of creation
and self-doubt and you know pricing and
uh customer experience and student
experience and design and funnels and
acquisition all these new words that you
know aren't familiar to us we're
learning and it's taking us a lot longer
than I think we anticipated um but I
feel really confident in the curriculum
we have a lot of learning to do on how
to be an Ali AB doll um but we are we
are learning and that everything takes
longer than you think and this is taking
us longer than we think and that's what
we're going to commit the next six
months to is extending this value prop
into paid
education nice and any final pieces of
parting wisdom for anyone who's listened
to the three hours of this podcast so
far wow you're here yeah welcome welcome
to the deep end welcome to the deep end
here as we call it we're we we Dove
really deep in this uh any parting words
of wisdom
um find as much time as you can to spend
time with yourself for me that has come
through the practice of of writing and
journaling um I can't recommend that
enough um but if that's something
different for you if that's listening to
music and going on a walk like like we
said all of this is self-discovery
whether it's entrepreneurship or
creativity and in order to do that you
have to create space and time for you to
spend time with
yourself uh I would say uh one of the
books I've really been enjoying and we
bring it up all the time is Rick rubin's
the creative act way of being and he
talks about how being an artist is about
practicing the art of
awareness and I think that has to do
with what Samir is talking about of like
spending time with yourself and being
aware so much of this career for us has
been about having a heightened sense of
awareness for what's comfortable what's
uncomfortable what's the right type of
discomfort what's the wrong type of
discomfort and so I think uh make sure
to build that muscle of awareness I
think that's what will ensure a
sustainable long-term career fantastic
thank you guys so much thanks thank you
all right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye-bye